scp-682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible
so Begins the SCP Foundation file on the
dreaded
scp-682 a highly intelligent reptilian
monster that has despite the
foundation's best efforts proved
impossible to kill it may not be the
most dangerous SCP out there considering
that some are capable of eliminating
entire realities but it's one of the
most iconic and you've probably heard
tales of the monster that death forgot
and you know exactly why everyone is so
afraid of the so-called hard to kill
reptile it's been subjected to some of
the most deadly weapons and traps the
foundation could devise and survived
attacks from some of its deadliest
fellow scps but before we tell you about
the foundation's many failed
assassination attempts against the
so-called hard to kill reptile we need a
little more groundwork on what this
creature even is the first thing to know
about scp-682 is that this thing wants
you and everything you know dead
unlike some other creatures like scp-096
and SCP-173 which are murderous but
exhibit no real higher processing skills
scp-682 possesses cunning Advanced
reasoning and even human level logical
intelligence
scp-682 can engage you in conversation
but just talking to the creature calmly
and cordially will sometimes cause it to
enter its rage stay where it becomes
even more dangerous and volatile the
Beast is perpetually kept in a tank of
powerful hydrochloric acid melting its
tissue to prevent it from reaching its
full potential and going on a rampage
the creature's most terrifying asset and
the reason it's proven impossible to
terminate thus far is its incredible
adaptability to any and all external
stimuli 682 is a reactive being capable
of not only surviving and regenerating
from all attacks but often incorporating
those attacks into its own wide Arsenal
in other words if you're hoping to kill
this thing you better kill it on the
first hit
because if you don't you better believe
it's gonna hit you back a hundred times
harder
this brings us to the main event some of
the SCP foundation's most ambitious and
frightening attempts to terminate
scp-682 or even understand how it could
theoretically be terminated there are
quite literally too many unsuccessful
attempts for us to list them all here so
think of this as a highlight reel of the
foundation's most prominent failures 682
was first cross-tested with scp-017 a
humanoid Shadow entity shown to be able
to consume matter with its shadows and
leave no traces behind test on tissue
samples from 682 showed that scp-017 was
able to consume said tissues with no
adverse effects however when scp-017 was
placed into the containment chamber with
the actual creature 682 let out a
horrific Roar that was so loud it
damaged nearby audio equipment
scp-017 fled to the corner of the room
and 682 in its rage State attempted to
breach containment agents managed to
suppress and remove the creature but no
meaningful damage was logged attempt
failed
SCP-173 the killer statue was later
brought in hoping that it's thus far
impeccable track record for killing
would hold strong the second that 173
was introduced into the testing area 682
retreated to the far wall and began
screeching intensely it was intelligent
enough to know what it was dealing with
here while the researchers and guards
expected an instantaneous reaction there
was actually a stalemate for over six
hours as 682 stared at 173 continuously
eventually the tie was broken when
agents shot out 682's eyes with high
caliber sniper rifles breaking the line
of sight and causing 173 to attack
though 682 sustained damage to several
parts of its body while its eyes were
generated the creature was not killed it
then regenerated a number of eyes all
over its body covered in a clear armored
carapace that made them resistant to
bullets the stalemate continued for an
additional 12 hours as 682 maintained
Perpetual eye contact 173 was eventually
removed from the containment unit and
the mission was aborted attempt failed
in their desperation the SCP Foundation
restored to bringing in another
dangerous and seemingly unkillable
monster to take on 682
scp-096 also known as the shy guy as
astute SCP fans will already know this
being kills anything that sees its face
with no known exceptions and when it
enters its attack mode it's thought to
be quite literally Unstoppable or at
least it was while scp-096 was able to
destroy 85 percent of 682's original
body mass during their 27 hour battle
it was left mentally broken wounded and
huddled in the corner to this day if
ever confronted with scp-682 the shy guy
reacts in pure Terror turning away and
clawing at its own face attempt failed
during a deadly Containment Breach
scp-682 also went head-to-head
organically with another iconic SCP Hall
of Famer
scp-106 also known as the old man the
old man and a shape-shifting psionic
anomaly known as scp-953 broke into
682's containment cell the old man
pulled both of his fellow anomalous
combatants into his pocket Dimension to
continue the battle on his terms however
despite losing 67 percent of his body
mass during the ensuing pocket Dimension
Showdown 682 still prevailed with the
old man eventually fleeing back to his
cell and 953 being collected and taken
away by agents once again
scp-682 continued to hold the title but
it wasn't just cross-testing experiments
intentional or otherwise the SCP
foundation's quest to kill 682 LED them
to a number of more conventional murder
methods all with varying degrees of
success due to scp-682's highly adaptive
abilities some methods were discounted
from the out
for example launching a powerful
thermonuclear missile at the creature
was soundly rejected by o5 command on
the premise that if the creature wasn't
destroyed and evolved to the point where
it could shrug off nukes Humanity would
be pretty much done for other ideas were
abandoned just for being too ridiculous
such as one researcher's suggestion to
fly the creature through the air and
drop it from a considerable height
hoping to kill it with a high altitude
impact I'm not sure we even need to tell
you why that's a terrible idea but
during the experiments on scp-682 the
studies range from honest to incompetent
to straight up evil
one guest researcher fed two small
innocent children to the creature just
to see what would happen he was then
himself fed to the creature for his
sadistic Behavior which was viewed as
getting in the way of his professional
conduct after all the foundation is
meant to be cold not cruel it was
scp-682 that had the Monopoly on cruelty
the medical agents were a resounding
failure they attempted to dismember 682
with a powerful laser only to have the
creature develop reflective services
that displaced the beam and caused
catastrophic damage to the area around
it they attempted to kill the creature
by sucking all the air out of its
containment facility and create a vacuum
but it expelled a dangerous gaseous
compound that reacted violently and
exploded when air was once again
introduced into the room the foundation
used High Precision Blades to slice
scp-682 into approximately 12 000 pieces
then separated these pieces
unsurprisingly by this point this
attempt also failed the 12 000 pieces
reformed a short while later into the
fully operational killing machine we all
know and fear in one particularly
frightening display of intelligence and
adaptability the foundation attempted to
kill 682 with extreme heat but it
shielded Itself by developing a second
car Pace composed of solid helium when
Personnel entered the room following the
failed attempt on the creature's life it
shattered its helium carapace into
deadly shards that fired around the room
and shredded all Foundation Personnel in
attendance it had set a trap and that
trap had been wildly successful the
creature's ability to adapt to seemingly
any offense is unparalleled to the point
where Foundation staff have no idea how
to classify this creature whether it's
organic inorganic or even alive at all
based on any definitions we could
understand
at every turn the creature just raised
more questions what is it is it possible
to destroy it at all by any means who
was even trying to kill who here because
it certainly seemed like scp-682 had a
masterful KD ratio by now more extreme
Feats of cross-testing continued in the
foundation's growing desperation to
eliminate this monster
scp-162 which is a hypnotic ball of
sharp objects Hooks and high tension
fishing line was introduced to 682's
containment cell the hooks latched onto
the creature and tore huge portions off
including its entire lower jaw and one
of its limbs however 682 was still able
to breach containment kill 11 people and
badly wound 86 others it regenerated its
severe injuries in no time the Beast was
even taken to the domain of the gate
Guardian one of the proposals for
scp-001 the guardian had a flaming sword
hotter than the sun capable of
destroying its Targets on an atomic
level
naturally scp-682 survived and
regenerated perhaps the most fascinating
cross-test of all was between 682 and
scp-053 who manifests as a kind innocent
little girl with the unfortunate
condition of causing homicidal
tendencies in all who come into contact
with her for more than 10 minutes
the people with these Tendencies would
then attempt to harm the girl but would
immediately drop dead shortly after
leaving the girl intact the researchers
present anticipated two possible
outcomes here the optimistic outcome in
which 682 enters a rage State attacks
0-5-3 and died for good and the
realistic outcome in which 682 attacks
053 possibly experiencing some minor
injury or nothing at all and 053 had to
be removed from the containment cell but
that didn't happen what did occur was
considerably more shocking than any kind
of violence when 053 entered 682's
containment chamber the monster became
uncharacteristically docile researchers
and staff were baffled and watched with
amazement as 053 approached the
terrifying Immortal Mass murdering
monster and began to play with it 682
even allowed 053 to draw on its face
with crayons researchers thought they
must have been dreaming seeing this
surreal display play out 053 even
appeared to have affection for this
unkillable misanthrope it was a single
act in defiance of everything they
thought they knew when Foundation
Personnel entered the containment cell
to separate the two 682 went ballistic
and killed multiple guards zero five
three also wept sad at being separated
from her new friend
to this day despite further testing the
foundation has no idea how or why this
happened like many details surrounding
scp-682 it shrouded in deeply
frustrating mystery
and so the tale of scp-682 continues in
spite of the foundation's best efforts
the monster continues to breach
containment and Slaughter with some
regularity taking out its seemingly
Limitless hatred for not only human
beings but anything that dares drop
breath nobody knows where exactly the
creature is from what its true nature is
or why its ability to adapt and
regenerate far exceeds any known
organism on this planet perhaps one day
through enough research and
cross-testing we can someday answer
these questions with scientific
Precision but until then we only have
one answer hatred Never Dies
ah here we go again it's time to return
to the acid-filled containment chamber
of
scp-682 more commonly known as the hard
to destroy reptile we've spoken about
him and the ways the SCP Foundation has
attempted to destroy him in a previous
video but as we said back then we really
only scratched the surface of the huge
number of insane ways the foundation has
tried to wipe this cranky lizard off the
face of the Earth today we're filling in
some of the cracks and taking a look at
the secret teslogs detailing the
foundation's unsuccessful quest to
finally destroy
scp-682 some of these may surprise you
and if you're a real SCP expert you may
just recognize some familiar faces we
meet along the way esteemed Foundation
researcher Dr Alto cleff famed for his
somewhat unconventional personality a
entered the test chamber to see if he
could intimidate the Beast to death this
resulted in a long staring contest
between Dr clef and 682 towards the end
of the competition Dr cleff began to
lose his nerve he tried to leave the
room only to find that the door was
locked causing him to swear loudly Dr
cleff Who always tries to find the most
direct solution to his problems blew up
the door with plastic explosives and ran
off the result test failed next came
scp-662 a silver handbell that summons
The supernaturally Helpful Butler Mr
Deeds when Mr Deeds was summoned
Foundation researchers asked him if he
could kill
scp-682 Deeds politely explained that he
wouldn't be capable of killing 682 it's
just too strong when he asked if he
could at least incapacitate 682 he
replied that the best way to do this
would be to poison himself and allow 682
to eat his body but this he reminded
would only be a temporary problem for
the lizard another test failed the
foundation brought in
scp-689 a terrifying soapstone statue of
a sitting skeleton that can kill you if
you see it and then stop paying
attention to it 682 first observed the
statue and then the foundation turned
off the lights when they turned them
back on
scp-682 appeared to be dead in a puddle
of gray and black liquid d-class
Personnel were sent in to confirm that
682 was actually dead but it instead got
up and killed them researchers theorized
that 682's definition of life is not
quite the same as ours rendering 689's
death-related Powers ineffective test
failed yet again
scp-807 was next up to bat this is an
anomalous salmon-colored ceramic dinner
plate with the words Last Chance Diner
printed on the edge in white any food
placed on it becomes Irresistible by any
definition but when the food is consumed
it causes immediate Cardiac Arrest due
to the sudden clogging of arteries with
fat researchers made a meal known as the
682 special 10 kilograms of rotten Mead
and sharpened bone splinters 10 liters
of rancid mayonnaise one liter of
potassium Cyanide and one kilogram of
morphine hydrochloride combined into a
solid mass and transmuted by 807 when
682 consumed this disgusting meal it
appeared to collapse however when
d-class Personnel were sent in again to
see whether 682 was truly out for the
count multiple holes opened up in its
body these holes fired out high pressure
Jets of blood killing the nearby
d-classes and destroying the containment
cell 682 was fine afterwards another
test failed to kill 682 it seemed that
the foundation really needed to have God
on their side so they tried to recruit
scp-343 also known as God to help them
destroy the Beast however when he
entered the containment chamber he
somehow couldn't even see the beast when
researchers asked him whether he could
kill 682 God replied he's not one of
mine deal with him yourself test failed
before it even began next the foundation
recruited
scp-524 a small white rabbit that can
eat literally anything including itself
without being harmed the rabbit was
released into scp-682's chamber at which
point it approached 682 and began to eat
one of its legs 682 roared in pain and
scuttled up the wall Out Of 524's Reach
where it remained for a number of hours
at this point scp-524 seemed to become
bored and began eating its way out of
containment through a nearby wall test
failed maybe the Luck of the Irish was
what the foundation needed to finally
put this monster to rest they recruited
scp-1933 a fat man dressed as Santa
Claus whose bodily fluids consist
entirely of the alcoholic beverage known
as Irish cream if enough of this man's
self-produced Irish cream is fed to
something they'll find that all of their
bodily fluids have become Irish cream
too killing them the foundation fed
large quantities of this Irish cream to
scp-682 and it actually had an effect
causing 682 to appear intoxicated which
was a promising sign however it soon
vomited out a massive quantity of
scp-1933 bodily fluids turning the walls
of its cell into Irish cream and
allowing it to escape and wreak havoc
test failed big time the foundation
recruited the help of
scp-2337 an intelligent Corn Creek known
as Dr spenko with a voice so loud it can
quite literally talk its victims to
death if it speaks to them for an
extended period of time it was sent into
a CPC 682's chamber to attempt to
destroy the beast but 682 just told it
to leave and the talkative bird obliged
by blowing away one of the chamber walls
with a yell allowing scp-682 to breach
containment again terrible job Dr spenko
test failed the foundation researchers
were starting to get a little frustrated
with their lack of progress which you
can no doubt sympathize with and they
even pitched the possibility of sending
scp-682 into an alternate Dimension
where perhaps it would enter into a
stalemate against its alternate self but
this pitch was shot down by the o5
Council on the grounds that it was way
way way way too risky back to the
drawing board by which we mean they
literally transformed 682's skin into a
kind of drawing board
scp-2521 is an anomaly that manifests
anytime information about it is recorded
and immediately grabs the source of the
information wrapping it in its tendrils
taking it away with it the foundation
sought to take advantage of this by
using a laser cutter to cut this
anomalous information into
scp-682's side however this didn't have
the results they were hoping for
scp-2521 did turn up to take the
information but it only took the skin on
which the information was carved 682
survived and quickly grew back its skin
test failed again researchers suggested
tracking down scp-169 an obscenely
massive underwater creature known as the
Leviathan and feeding 682 to the Beast
however this idea was also immediately
shot down by the o5 council if 682 did
what it did best which was surviving
attacks and adding them to its own
Arsenal then it might grow to the size
of
scp-169 which would likely trigger an XK
Class end of the world scenario it
simply was not worth the risk test
failed before it even started the
foundation released two specimens of
scp-939 into 682's test chamber these
voice imitating Amnesia inducing
monsters have caused huge damage to
human targets so it was hope that they
may be able to do something to 682 but
this hope turned out to be misplaced
both specimens seemed extremely
distressed by 682's presence and refused
to engage at all 682 did not share the
same apprehension about attacking it
charged in and brutally killed both
before devouring their corpses test
failed in a very well-documented case
the adorable scp-999 was introduced into
682's test chamber The unassailable Good
Vibes provided by 999 as well as an
intense tickle fight did actually lead
to the temporary incapacitation of
scp-682 however the otherwise wholesome
incident ended in tragedy when 682
adapted to the Good Vibes and was able
to release a kind kind of violent
laughter wave this incapacitated much of
the staff and allowed 682 to breach
containment and go on another Killing
Spree before being recontained test once
again failed the next test involved
scp-294 an anomalous coffee machine that
can produce any liquid typed into its
keypad Foundation researchers requested
scp-682 killer from the machine and were
astounded by the results during tests on
the liquid with scp-682 tissue samples
the liquid was surprisingly effective
and caused the 682 tissue to Decay and
crumble tests on the living creature
were similarly promising the acid in
682's tank was temporarily lowered and
one liter of scp-682 killer was poured
onto the reptile's head causing that
portion of its flesh to immediately
Decay when the acid was returned the
same portion that had the liquid poured
on it dissolved instantly 10 test well
not quite successful but promising and
requiring further Research Foundation
scientists believe that if they could
one day get a large enough quantity of
this liquid they might have a viable
option but until then the tests march on
for another experiment they introduced
scp-055 into the containment chamber of
scp-682
scp-055 also known as the self-keeping
secret is a mysterious anomaly that can
only be described by what it isn't for
example we know that scp-055 is not
round but that was pretty much it now
however we know something else about
scp-055 that it can't kill
scp-682 test failed but at least we know
twice as much about scp-055 as we did
before next came
scp-082 better known as Fernand the
cannibal fernan was first presented a
piece of Flesh from 682 the rad other
than eating it he inspected it and began
to express joy that his friends still
live when introduced into 682's testing
chamber Ferdinand attempted to subdue
the lizard and use it as his Steed 682
expressed an intense hatred for both
Ferdinand and the idea of being ridden
like a pony and the two of them engaged
in combat mobile task forces were
eventually brought in to subdue both
subjects in a debrief interview both
hinted that they shared history prior to
containment but 682 was reluctant to
talk about it further test entertaining
but still a failure researchers were
becoming extremely frustrated with
scp-682's unwillingness to die so they
called in an SCP who responded to reason
much better
scp-049 the plague doctor this Sinister
surgeon can kill with a touch and the
foundation hoped that his abilities
would extend to 682 however the result
was a dud the plague doctor did touch
682 but it experienced no adverse
effects and eventually swiped at the
doctor upon leaving 049 reported feeling
emotionally disturbed by his encounter
with scp-682 yep you guessed it test
failed if he gives you any indication of
just how desperate the researchers were
at this point Dr Graham pondered whether
introducing 682 to a human with just as
pessimistic and misanthropic feelings as
itself would somehow pacify it they sent
in a particularly nasty d-class and the
two spoke fascinatingly 682 didn't
attempt to harm this d-class they just
shared their profane and Bleak
sentiments about the human race with one
another however some of 682's opinions
were a little too spicy for this d-class
after listening to the reptile speak for
20 minutes the d-class fell into a
catatonic state from the sheer
depression of it all he died not long
after one researcher suggested perhaps
the worst idea of letting scp-682 out
into the wild not even really to
terminate it just to see what it does
the scientists figured there would be
some Merit in analyzing the creature's
Behavior this idea was submitted
anonymously of course it seems even the
most sadistic of researchers know better
than to put their name on an idea like
that as you can probably guess this
request was shot down by the o5 council
the note attached to the request by one
of its members summed it up best I'll
tell you what it will do it'll go out
for a nice stroll murder a few innocent
people go fishing slaughter a few more
innocent people start up a tech company
eat a few more innocent people go on a
vacation to Florida dismember a few more
innocent people I swear when I find out
who wrote this you can personally enter
682's containment chamber to analyze him
yourself this has been far from an
exhaustive account of all the different
ways the SCP Foundation has tried to
terminate
scp-682 but it shouldn't be surprising
that all of their ideas have either been
failures or were too risky to even try
sadly for the SCP Foundation and the
human race it's likely we'll be dealing
with scp-682 for a long time to come
scp-682 does it even require an
introduction the SCP Foundation thinks
this cantankerous reptile needs a
serious attitude adjustment by which we
mean they really really want to kill it
but as you might have seen in our
previous videos on the subject they
don't call this monstrosity the hard to
destroy reptile for nothing that's why
we've done what the foundation isn't
allowed to we Outsource the dirty job of
squashing this lizard to all of you we
made a community post asking for your
ideas on how this scaly Abomination can
finally be destroyed and you delivered
Big Time a truly staggering amount with
over 6 000 comments now let's see if we
can finally get our answer because leave
us the foundation is desperate at this
point I don't know what to write for a
name said the most effective way that Dr
bright approves of Chainsaw Canon as
awesome as a chainsaw Cannon would
probably be to use it certainly wouldn't
be very effective against
scp-682 chainsaws are blades and we know
from the termination test logs that
blades have been ineffective even when
scp-682 is chopped up into tiny little
pieces those pieces have a nasty habit
of reforming into the big ugly monster
we all know and fear awesome Cardinals
said the SCP Foundation could try to
bring it to the void in Russia where the
pattern screamers are this was a popular
idea and the foundation actually tried
this the SCP being referred to here is
scp-3930 a big old pile of nothing in
Russia that causes things inside it to
stop existing when they threw scp-682
inside it technically did stop existing
despite this it could still proceed and
still caused the deaths of all
surrounding researchers 15 hours later
it just reappeared in its containment
chamber apparently totally fine you can
probably see why the foundation is
frustrated by this thing score Crow and
friends said black hole need I say more
you may need to say a little more for
starters there would be logistical
issues in actually getting the creature
anywhere near a black hole but there's
also the concern that it may just adapt
its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole or
even scarier somehow adapt to reproduce
the powers of a black hole it probably
wouldn't be worth the risk of ending up
with a reptile capable of creating gamma
ray bursts Stellar solar Sky said put
the reptile inside nuclear fusion and
watch its particles disappear the
foundation tried something pretty close
to this by trying to put it inside
scp-536 a chamber where they can use
dials to control the physical contents
with defend they increased the speed of
light and nuclear force within the
chamber which caused scp-682 to
disintegrate until all that was left was
a piece of matter one percent of its
original size however the creature then
reformed and killed the researchers
later tests showed that its body had
become an unknown form of matter held
together by Quantum effects impossible
to unravel with our current
understanding of science Brea fund said
so you know that coffee machine thing
that is 294 type in 682 killing
substance and then repeat that until you
have enough to fill its entire room then
fill it they did actually try this the
resulting substance was effective in
damaging
scp-682's tissue however the one problem
is that it's extremely difficult to
produce enough of this stuff to actually
submerge the creature worse still if
enough was made to cause significant
damage to the body of scp-682 it may
adapt to the chemical as a defense
mechanism making it ineffective as a
weapon it's a ability is truly
scp-682's greatest asset when it comes
to thwarting the foundation's constant
attempts to kill it Alex Webb said ask
it kindly to die we don't believe that
the foundation has actually ever tried
this one but just based on the fact that
scp-682 is a huge jerk on top of being
an omnicidal monster he probably
wouldn't respond to polite requests I
Flash Boys said I wonder if Doom Slayer
could defeat the reptile he's torn
through every demon in hell and even
Titans so with 682 be a challenger or
just another Tuesday for the Slayer
that's a slightly trickier one of course
since they exist in different universes
we'll never see an official battle
between the Doom Slayer and scp-682
however given that the Doom slayer's
weapons are all conventional meaning
largely based around slashing crushing
shooting and Blasting we don't know
whether he'd actually be able to slay
the Beast that being said we don't know
if 682 could kill him either we could
have stalemate on our hands here Amanda
brennaman said I asked my sister who's
never heard of scp's this question and
her answer was you hid it again Amanda
your sister may be the one to finally
stop this creature getting the two of
them in the same room may be the biggest
logistical problem here Samuel Pasquale
said throwing him down scp-087 so he
suffers and is contained once and for
all in the improbable case he is still
alive
scp-087 the endless staircase can be a
dangerous anomaly for humans who don't
know what they're getting into however
scp-682 would likely detect the threat
far earlier than any human and then
breach containment it's definitely
gotten out of stickier situations
yashashiri Shara said send him to
endless Ikea where he will be trapped
forever much like scp-087 the endless
Ikea would impose the same threat to
scp-682 as it would for the average
human trapped inside the staff would be
no trouble for 682 and it would be able
to devote pretty much all of its time in
there to finding a way out and when he
did finally break out he'd probably be
armed with a terrifying knowledge of how
to correctly assemble a spending throat
we shudder at the thought Jack Moss said
oxygen Destroyer used to deal with
another big lizard issue back in 1954.
sadly this would also likely be an
ineffective weapon against
scp-682 because the creature thrives in
anaerobic environments seeing as its
native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen and according to Foundation tests
it can survive just fine in a vacuum
whether scp-682 could take Godzilla in a
fight is still up for debate and you can
argue about which lizard would reign
supreme in the comments Ace Goodwin said
just don't kill him let him live bro he
hasn't done anything wrong yet let him
vibe in his chamber wait a second did
scp-682 write this moving on a lot of
you said throw him into the sun while
the sun is a gigantic nuclear furnace
where hydrogen is built into helium at a
temperature sure of millions of degrees
there is the issue of not only being
Beyond difficult to incapacitate the
creature for long enough to get into the
rocket but also the problem of the sun
being 93 million miles away from Earth
it's a long trip there no matter what
and during that time scp-682 would
almost definitely figure out a way to
return to Earth it might even rewire the
rocket and turn it into its own personal
vehicle giving it the freedom to cause
chaos around the solar system and even
if everything else went well
scp-682 would still probably survive
being thrown into the sun after all the
gate guardian's flaming sword is
described as being hotter than the Sun
and it didn't manage to kill the hard to
destroy reptile Pokemon red boy said
send him to Mars and launch a nuke that
can destroy a planet along with the SCP
while a nuke capable of destroying the
planet of Mars would also likely destroy
scp-682 in the process the destruction
of Mars itself would likely cause such a
catastrophic shift in our neck solar
system that we'd probably die along with
it the question at that point is whether
it's really worth killing ourselves to
take down the lizard Artemis said let it
live with 999 its entire life and it's
not a threat this is a double-edged
sword during their cross test
scp-999 did pacify scp-682 and put it in
a state of bliss and laughter for a
brief period however this actually
resulted in a pretty catastrophic
tragedy too 682 adapted to 999's effects
and released a beam of laughter that
incapacitated everyone around it
allowing it to escape and go on a
killing spree so maybe the two are
better kept apart doctor was up said I'd
give 682 a jar of pickles to open and
the jar would be so tight that scp-682
couldn't open it and he would be so
embarrassed by it that he would just
destroy himself you may actually be on
to something here we know we'd be
extremely embarrassed if we couldn't
open the jar but there are three major
problems one where does one get such a
jar can scp-343 make a jar of pickles so
difficult to open that he himself can
open it two we don't know if scp-682
likes pickles enough to make opening the
jar an attractive Prospect and three if
it does turn out that it likes pickles
it would probably just eat the jar too
shuvo batachi said to deal with him in
my opinion send scp-682 into scp-3001
aka the red reality that's my theory
this could potentially Be an Effective
method of trapping scp-682 for a period
of time however the problem is that
there's no reliable way to access the
red reality the only person who's ever
really been inside is Robert Scranton
and he ended up there completely by
accident so this doesn't seem to be a
reliable neutralization method for
scp-682 adding to that the panel that Dr
Scranton was transported to the red
reality with eventually came back which
means it might only be a temporary
solution anyway mistake to society yay
said Can someone write scp-682 without
them dying this isn't technically about
neutralizing scp-682 but it deserves an
answer while it appears that some people
are able to ride 682 such as scp-053 the
little girl and o5-6 aka the American in
the orboro cycle he doesn't seem to
enjoy it at least he didn't when scp-082
better known as Ferdinand the cannibal
attempted it of course Ferdinand
describes the relationship quite
differently insisting that 682 is his
Bayard his magical Steed Laura Garcia
said chop it up put the pieces in a
giant bowl with egg beaters stirring it
constantly so it can't reanimate keep it
kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform Giant Egg
beating machine to prevent Reformation
killing it would take a rival sunblast
to stop it from reanimating itself this
has got to be one of the most creative
ones we've encountered even Dr Bry
probably wouldn't think to use Giant
whisks on the Beast however it probably
wouldn't kill the ordinary creature for
good as we've said before not only has
the Beast regenerated from things as hot
as the sun he's also able to re-manifest
from the tiniest atoms or even nothing
at all on the plus side he may reanimate
with a new super whisking ability and
could potentially give scp-5031 a run
for best cook and containment shaked Ben
yakar said I think they need to explode
him from the inside because maybe
there's one spot in this body that isn't
invincible and if they hurt it scp-682
will die the problem with scp-682 isn't
necessarily that it's Invincible just
hyper adaptive and Hyper regenerative as
you may have seen in other videos
scp-682 has been shot dismembered burned
Frozen vaporized blown up partially
eaten and even totally disintegrated but
it always manages to come back even from
the smallest specs of matter it would
almost be admirable if it wasn't a
perpetually aggressive murder monster
breibot said put it in 106's Pocket
Dimension this actually happened once
during a Containment Breach where the
old man as well as scp-953 the
polymorphic humanoid ended up in 682's
cell
scp-106 dragged them all into its pocket
dimension for a bit of the odd Ultra
violence and when they emerged it was
clear that they'd all taken considerable
damage
scp-682 wasn't killed though and 106
hasn't tried anything like that again
since non-player Cactus said trick him
into killing John Wick's dog to be fair
if anyone could take this monster down
it'd probably be John Wick though
scp-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place and if
he did manage to best John Wick well we
hate to think what a 682 with a marshall
prowess and gun skills of John Wick
would be like actually no we don't need
to think about it because it would be
awesome the these are just a little
taster plate of the huge and varied
potential murder methods you've devised
for this terrible creature but there
were just too many good ones so we'll
have to save the rest for another day ah
here we go again it's time for us to
take another crack at putting scp-682
six feet under once and for all if
you've been following this channel for
any amount of time then there's one
thing you know for certain
scp-682 is harder to kill than pretty
much well anything we've made multiple
videos on the foundation's failed
attempts to finally terminate the Beast
and we've made a video with some of your
ideas on how to finally slay the monster
and considering you're watching this
video right now you can probably guess
how that went now it's time for one more
run at the Death Star and once again
it's with your ideas from comments and
Community post responses let's see if
any of them can help us finally put this
ill-tempered reptile to rest if we can't
well we're not blaming you but it's also
your fault let the community termination
attempts commence anas McBride suggested
ask the witch child
scp-239 also known as the witch child is
one of the most dangerous and Powerful
anomalies out there she's a small girl
with unparalleled reality warping mental
abilities so powerful that her very
brain waves alone can be passively fatal
however the problem is her power is so
potentially dangerous that she's forever
kept in a kind of medically induced
anomalous coma Dr Alto Klatt thinks
she's so dangerous he's even campaigning
to have her terminated as a result the
o5 council has forbidden any
cross-testing between 682 and 239
fearing the consequence of 682 gaining
239's powers and becoming a truly
Unstoppable threat capable causing an XK
Class end of the world scenario sierra
mean Alicia kazimi mushadi suggested
kill him with scp-734 this is an
interesting one
scp-734 also known as the baby is an
anomaly that causes a painful
degenerative disease that eventually
disintegrates the entire body and kills
the victim if they so much has come into
contact with the baby or its fluids
however based on Cross tests with other
similar touch it and die anomalies like
scp-409 the contagious Crystal we can
probably guess how exactly this would go
down in all likelihood the baby's
anomalous effects would infect and
Destroy large portions of
scp-682's body however at this point 682
would adapt to the threat and begin to
reverse it and heal even worse it's
likely that 682 would steal the ability
for a limited time and become deadly to
the touch Kaden Griffin suggested why
don't you use the dragon slayer to
terminate 682 it has proved itself many
times in fights with lsas
scp-5514 the dragon slayer is
essentially a giant fighting robot
designed to take down killer kaijus with
its plethora of state-of-the-art
anomalous weapons and defenses however
we'd still argue that while it could
definitely help in immobilizing 682
during a rampage it doesn't have much of
a chance of actually killing it let's
look at scp-001 the gate Guardian a
supernatural warrior with a blade hotter
than the sun capable of cleaving atoms
in half even he couldn't kill
scp-682 so robotic approximation with
only a fraction of the gate guardian's
power is probably not going to have any
real chance of killing 682 I'm a
chuckster 48 suggested make it bite its
tongue so hard that it just destroys
itself while we can certainly attest
from personal experience that this
really really hurts we worry that if
ever 682 bit its own tongue really hard
it'd just drive it into a state of
murderous rage though we do take a small
piece of satisfaction and knowing its
tongue would probably be in distress for
a few minutes afterwards it's unlikely
to wipe out the Beast once and for all
lazy rolly suggested how about we just
put scp-682 and 2317 cell
scp-2317 is an old wooden door that
functions as a portal into the domain of
the planet destroying monster known as
the Devourer of Worlds a being that many
believe is associated with the Scarlet
King and will inevitably escape and
cause an XK Class end of the world
scenario while you may be thinking
perhaps it'll kill 682 it's more likely
that it'll collaborate seeing as they
both want the same thing namely to kill
everyone if you let 682 in chances are
it'll come back through the door with
the Devourer right on its tail then it's
all of our problems guest one two three
one one six suggested drop him in Russia
so they can terminate him the foundation
has technically already tried this they
dropped 682 into scp-3930 a patch of
literal non-existence in Russia that
causes anything that goes inside of it
to cease to exist and afterwards he was
fine so yeah dropping him and anywhere
in Russia is probably just going to get
a bunch of innocent Russian civilians
killed maisher said the foundation
shouldn't worry about how to kill him
but how to stop his ability to adapt I
would suggest typing scp-682 no
adaptability juice or something like
that into scp-294 and then kill him by
any means which should kill him forever
an interesting Theory but what if he
simply adapts to scp-682 no adaptability
juice then we'd really all be in trouble
Mario tgp said give him a Twitter
account he'll be canceled instantly for
his spicy opinions
scp-682 would cancel Twitter itself for
not having opinions that are spicy
enough sorry Jack
scp-096 Still soar about losing the
battle we assume said let him fight the
Queen of England after all she's
Immortal too we definitely think it
would be interesting to see scp-682 go
head to head with the Queen of England
based on all the nighting she does we
know that she at least has a sword
though we don't know if that sword is as
powerful as the one wielded by the gate
Guardian but regardless of the outcome
the battle would definitely change
history every history book would simply
read
scp-682 punched the queen everything
else would just be a footnote Noah
Cordero said use
scp-2935 to kill the lizard as you can
see in the video he will die
scp-2935 also known as odaf is probably
one of the scariest and deadliest scps
out there it killed an entire alternate
Dimension including an alternate
scp-682 the problem is putting r682 into
2935's alternate reality could lead to
the destruction of our entire Dimension
why is that because if 682 was somehow
able to return to our world from the
world of 2935 it could bring the spirit
of death itself back with it and kill us
all in the process explorando con Beto
once suggested
scp-682 vs lady matrese while Resident
Evil AIDS lady dimitrisk has certainly
captured all of our hearts we don't
think she'll be bringing home the W on
this one lady dimitrisk has a powerful
adaptive ability of her own with a high
resistance to damage impressive
regenerative abilities and a number of
offensive capabilities from huge claws
to a powerful Dragon form however
considering she wasn't able to defeat
Ethan Winters she probably wouldn't be
able to defeat
scp-682 either however in her Dragon
form as cp682 May finally join the rest
of us in developing a crush or is that
being crushed anyway moving on Jonathan
pekines suggested just ask scp-343 on
how to destroy it or even better ask if
he could destroy it it's an idea so good
that the foundation actually tried it
and it went about as well as you can
expect when the SCP known as God entered
the containment chamber he couldn't even
see 682 in there as though the creature
was somehow totally invisible to him
when God eventually got bored and left
they told him that he was in there to
destroy 682 he simply replied he's not
one of mine deal with him yourself
interpret that how you will 12 Escobar
Blanca's Eddie Saul suggested they could
send him to area 37 for the Sisters to
experiment with
scp-1765 the sisters are a trio of
terrifyingly powerful reality warpers
that have taken over area 37 and spend
their days tormenting everyone inside
with their Twisted experiments using
them to try to terminate 682 leads to
similar problems with using the witch
child or the Devourer of Worlds if they
decide to team up rather than fighting
or the sisters take over 682 we'd all be
effectively doomed kiroya suggested with
the ants from scp-743 tear 682 apart the
foundation actually tried this getting
682 to consume chocolate from The
scp-743 Fountain incurring the wrath of
its fleshy ants however 682 developed an
adaptation that gave it a long
anteater-like tongue that it then used
to consume the ants faster than they
could consume it and even worse the
chocolate seemed to enhance its
regenerative abilities even more for
several days afterwards ball 2222
suggested write the name in The Death
Note great idea we'll put it into
practice as soon as you can tell us as
cp682's real name it may come as a
surprise but its parents didn't actually
name it the hard to destroy reptile
Stephen Fury suggested I thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant
blender and then when he's in small
pieces put lava in the blender so it
will incinerate him then put nuclear
waste into the blender and repeat that
until there is no more left of him after
the cooking whisks last time we feel
obliged to include at least one attempt
to kill scp-682 with oversized kitchen
equipment in every video about him
however this attempt would probably go
about as well as the last one were
afraid extreme physical trauma by
conventional means like burning and
dismemberment has never been successful
in the past and the foundation is
extremely hesitant to use anything
Radioactive on the beast in case it
adapts and adds deadly radiation to its
own Arsenal Mr Master IQ suggested just
take away his plot armor you can pry
scp-682's plot armor from its cold dead
Claws and as we've already learned
making those claws cold and dead seems
next to Impossible moving on jc3
suggested hmm if anyone can't beat the
undying lizard why not omniman I mean he
did kill all the Guardians of the globe
of course he can kill scp-682 Omni man
from the comic and TV series Invincible
is undeniably a formidable opponent
given he's able to destroy superhero
teams cities and even planets however
one of the few enemies to give omniman a
genuine run for his money is a
Genetically Enhanced Kaiju known as Hail
Mary given that first 682 is taking on
being stronger than Omni man like the
gate guardian and lived and second that
omniman has struggled with monsters
before chances are he probably couldn't
permanently kill this one either hey
Kenny javea suggested kill scp-053 then
682 will be sad and die wow now that's
cold-blooded however even if this did
work it's important for you to remember
that it's impossible to actually kill
scp-053 also known as the child or the
little girl part of her anomalous
abilities is that anyone who attempts to
kill her will themselves immediately die
during the process normally due to a
heart attack so this method would result
in a pile of dead Foundation personnel
and no progress Jerry Zhang said mush
peanut butter on it this would
definitely work if 682 had some kind of
severe peanut allergy after all
anaphylactic shock is no laughing matter
however in the far more likely event
that this will have no effect on scp-682
you will likely just die with your hands
covered in peanut butter Andrew Mills
suggested my idea have several
Xenomorphs predators and Daleks yes
that's a doctor who reference take 682
on once again in all likelihood this
would have no effect 682 has survived
blades and lasers the Primary Weapons of
the Predators and Daleks and spends the
majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid so the xenomorph would
hold no surprises for it sadly this
three-way team up would be no match for
682 and even if it did defeat him
whoever wins we um well you know how it
goes Mateo Huang suggested maybe just
destroy reality this this might be the
thing that finally kills scp-682 but
considering it's already survive being
thrown into pure nothingness in Russia
it may just result in it being one of
the only survivors of a full destruction
of reality we on the other hand would
all be killed though in a sense we
wouldn't have to deal with scp-682
anymore so maybe that's a type of
winning and finally blind honor
suggested would saitama be a good way to
eliminate it he is one punch man after
all of anyone we've covered in this
series saitama from one punch man would
probably be the most likely to kill
scp-68v2 especially if he was taking the
battle seriously after all he has killed
Planet destroying monsters before with
barely any effort the only real question
is whether he could be bothered to come
down to a foundation containment site
and fight it saitama hasn't been known
to be a very motivated guy but of course
like with anything there's the risk that
682 would survive and gain his powers
which would be bad awesome but bad those
blasted Foundation rats had done it
again
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile sat
in its tank of highly concentrated acid
and seethed at the world it had been
placed in and what a miserable terrible
World it
he hated it and he hated every single
soul that occupied it and especially the
hypocritical monsters in the lab coats
that ran this sham of an organization
whenever the reptile wasn't speaking
normally to bark threats and profanities
at its human jailers it was quietly
listening taking everything in and how
the things it heard made its blood boil
more than the corrosive fluid forever
eating into its carapace what
high-minded ideas these worthless Apes
had about themselves were cold not cruel
what a sick joke every moment for the
reptile was a different kind of Hell the
Baseline of existence was a certain dull
fizzling pain as he melted as quickly as
his cells could divide his only reprieve
from this was being dragged into a
testing chamber for some even worse pain
perhaps burned or sliced or chewed at by
a mutant rabbit or crushed by bananas
were torn apart by wires and hooks or
beaten and bashed by some mad swordsman
or having his mind invaded and attacked
by a Rogue Soul in a cursed necklace if
this was only cold then the reptile
hated to even imagine what the SCP
Foundation considered cruel after all
there were monsters more powerful than
him out there the hanged king or the
Devourer of Worlds could handedly
destroy their wretched ball of rock if
they so choose to he wasn't the most
sadistic or evil of the beasts these
maniacs and white coats had faced those
who Ward with him met a quick death at
his claws and fangs would that
nightmarish old man afford his victim
such a luxury or that Unstoppable
psychopath in the old police car and yet
it was his file that bore the addendum
scp-682 must be destroyed as soon as
possible and why seemingly only because
he could take it and the foundation
always had new toys it wanted to a test
on their favorite punching bag of course
he attempted to escape but wouldn't you
is freedom not an inalienable right the
foundation would cry but look at the
terrible crimes he's committed look at
the lives he's taken as they always do
let he who is without sin draw the first
Acid Bath he knew on some level if he
were to make a tally the foundation's
crimes would far outnumber his own the
only difference was that they deluded
themselves into believing all acts of
Cruelty are permissible in service of
their greater good if they all had but
one head the reptile would clot from
their shoulders a group of incredibly
well-armed and well-armored guards
entered the room training all their
weapons on him he hadn't summoned the
energy to escape today and that meant
only one thing they were going to take
another swing at killing him again oh
goody another attempt that would leave
him momentarily in absolute agony and
allow neither of them to gain any ground
he'd grow numb to attempts on his life
by now whatever they had waiting for him
in the other room he'd be ready for it
the guards removed him from his Acid
Bath And while he was still trying to
regenerate his muscles and nerves enough
to move they dragged him into the
testing chamber it was always a mystery
wondering what they'd be poking or
prodding him with today but when he was
first dragged into the chamber it was
empty those were always the worst ones
when he was left some Sitting Duck
waiting for the foundation in their
infinite malice to choose the form of
the would-be Destroyer what would be
behind door number one a box a large
wooden box was pushed into the room and
the door closed behind it how curious
the hard to destroy reptile began to
approach the Box sniffing at the air it
made no sound in there but something
about that smell something
eerily familiar it was different this
time with a soft pop the Box fell apart
its walls falling in different
directions like The Petal of a blooming
flower and the second the hard to
destroy reptiles saw what lurked inside
it felt an unfamiliar cold Barb of
Terror hook into the soft warm flesh of
its heart the thing inside the Box had
been called SCP-173 by the SCP
Foundation but that wasn't how the
reptile knew it it was a primordial
nightmare an ancient horror the stone
devil the killer in the dark the koi
term which had mercilessly and gleefully
slaughtered so much of the reptile's
very species back when 682 was known as
the
atantikilipendio and here it was ready
to finish the job
scp-682 let out an involuntary Screech
of pure horror and fled backwards
keeping its eyes fixed on the monster at
all times he moved back until he hit the
far wall of the containment chain until
he could go no further his mind was
flooded and his heart was racing he
never thought he'd see this monster
again he'd hoped it would never cross
his path again perhaps he even held out
hope that the Abomination had been slain
destroyed scattered to the winds and yet
here it was looking at him the reptile
called out
what you've done this thing
mark my words it would be your ruin it
will Slaughter every single one of you
but its appeals to reason with its
captors in their own interest for once
fell on utterly uninterested ears six
hours of this past the reptile spending
every second of it for the first time in
a long time fearing for his life a group
of observing Foundation scientists
merely noted A peculiar reaction of
distress from 682 and ordered a
decorated mobile task for Sharpshooter
with a Barrett 50 caliber sniper rifle
with armor-piercing rounds to initiate
phase two of the Cross test in a sudden
flash of sound and pain the Sharpshooter
blew away both of scp-682's staring eyes
the simultaneous instruction went out
for all observing members of personnel
to avert their gaze just for a moment
682 could certainly regenerate its eyes
quickly but nothing was quite as fast as
an unobserved
SCP-173 the reptile screeched in pain as
it heard the monster snapping its body
parts leaving it thoroughly mutilated
when the group of observing scientists
look back they saw it which is to say
SCP-173 standing before a heavily
damaged
scp-682 as though incredibly proud of
its handiwork internally 682 thanked a
Creator it despised for the fact that
the observers looked back and spared it
from the onslaught that soulless Stone
monster had Unleashed on it a scientist
working for the foundation would later
remark after review it appears SCP-173
was unable to do lethal damage to
scp-682 due to a major difference in
physical size a possible repeat of this
test may be made if scp-682 is damaged
enough to reduce its physical Mass to a
level equal with SCP-173 but 682 knew
deep down this wasn't the truth it had
nothing to do with physical size if the
koi turn had truly willed it he never
would have left that room the monster
only wanted to extend the torment and
this time
scp-682 wouldn't let him he regenerated
adapted and came back ready 682
developed a number of eyes far more than
before that remained fixed on SCP-173
paralyzing it it crawled back up onto
the wall and simply stared once again
the observing scientists ordered the
Sharpshooter to take aim in open fire
but this time the bullets had no effect
scp-682 had developed a thick clear
carapace over the surface of its new
eyes ensuring that nothing would break
its eye contact with that murderous
little monster this time it would not
lose but for all the time that 682
stared 173 said nothing as always it
just stood there the strange pattern of
its face that nasty bloody Rorschach
splotch looked almost like a mocking
smile it conceded nothing it seemed to
say go on get an eyeful I have all the
time in the universe and everyone looks
away eventually even you atantikul Pena
let the Eternal Silence of your brethren
be a lesson to you all you will hear is
crunch 682 kept up the staring contest
for 12 hours before it was taken back to
its Acid Bath thoroughly shaken by its
experience it had always despised its
terrible captors but now a new shade of
Darkness had entered its narrow
emotional lexicon fear true fear and
acknowledgment deep down in its muscle
tissue and guts that there was something
out there that could truly hurt it the
terrible koi turn was alive and thirsty
for blood the researchers who conducted
this test considered it an interesting
partial success while 682 was quaking in
its tank thinking about 173 they were
brainstorming the best move to take next
regarding potential pairings between 682
and 173 a Plucky researcher noted that
096 had also gotten scp-682 on the ropes
so maybe they should send in 173 with a
photo of scp-096 taped to its chest a
member of the o5 council intervened
before this got too far saying no
absolutely not setting aside the problem
of scp-682 and SCP-173 that cannot be
observed for fear of triggering a
response from scp-096 is a
self-perpetuating catastrophe that the
foundation does not under any reasonable
circumstances have the slightest desire
to unleash denied with vehemence the
researcher who suggested this idea felt
supremely embarrassed and retired
briefly to one of the employee bathrooms
to have a good cry before returning to
the brainstorming session researcher
matus a more experienced member of
personnel had a stroke of Genius he
reminded the assembled researchers that
they'd recently performed another
semi-successful experiment on 682 using
their deadly High Precision Blades they
were able to slice and dice 682 into a
series of amorphous blobs sure these
blobs may have attacked and killed some
d-classes before reforming into the OG
nasty reptile but each of these blobs
were the perfect size to be murdered by
SCP-173 it eliminated the size
differential and put these two on an
even playing field and on that even
playing field it stood to reason that
SCP-173 might win the cross test was
greenlit and a researcher named Dr
Shenron was put in charge of overseeing
the operations and this time due to
Foundation incompetence and a greater
degree of mental preparedness by scp-682
they were in for a complete disaster 682
and 173 were brought into the same
containment chamber 682 could feel the
latent fear welling up inside itself so
it did the thing that it knew the best
it tried to stoke up its rage its hatred
the fury and spite that had kept it
going through so many torturous attempts
on its life it would not die at the
hands of this Stone monster and if it
was its Destiny then it would ensure
with its dying wretched breaths it would
destroy this terrible Beast once and for
all it would shatter it and ensure it
never put itself back together suddenly
the high Precision Blades were deployed
it was an endless volley of cutting that
dashed the two deadly anomalies to
pieces like a giant As Seen On TV Slap
Chop because the machine had been
calibrated for its body 682 was sliced
into 12 000 perfect cubes and 173 had
been cut into a pile of lumpy irregular
chunks a vacuum system was then
activated to separate both anomalies
into different chambers so 173 could
reform and begin the assault but
miraculously for 682 the vacuum system
failed 2D classes were sent in to
recalibrate the system but things
quickly got even worse many of the 682
cubes formed the same gelatinous masses
that they did in the previous High
Precision Blades test and began
attacking and killing one of the
d-classes the other naturally turned to
look at this horrifying display which
meant nobody was paying attention to
SCP-173 immediately the sculpture
reformed and snapped the surviving
d-class's neck before turning its
attention to scp-682 the emergency
incineration system failed so all the
foundation could hope for was mutually
assured destruction until they got the
situation back under control however the
foundation had underestimated 682's
intelligence and tactical reasoning
while the gelatinous mutated Globs of
its flesh attacked 173 smashing and
cracking its concrete body as it killed
and splattered them the remainder of
682's flash formed a smaller version of
itself which began staring at 173 this
froze the sculpture in place while the
mutated flesh monsters smashed into it
slowly breaking it down for the first
time in as long as it could remember 682
felt genuinely the thrill of Revenge the
glory of an ancient foe vanquished it
would now slay the a terrible koi turn
as its ancestors had tried to do so many
times before and failed but this reptile
would not fail until of course the SCP
Foundation monsters that they were
decided to put their finger on the scale
the same Foundation mobile task force
Sharpshooter who'd been there during the
first 173 cross-test was still there
still ready to carry out his duties on
the order of the researchers he fired
another two shots blowing out the eyes
of this new smaller 682 while it
regenerated its precious eyes 173 went
on a rampage mercilessly slaughtering
every single one of the eyeless Blobs of
mutated flesh it smashed each one Beyond
repair until only it and the smaller 682
remained luckily for 682 its eyes
regenerated complete with the familiar
bulletproof covering just in time to
hold back 173 from killing it the two
remain locked in the staring contest of
pure hatred for a solid 17-hour hours
before the test was eventually called
off but the horrors continued exhausted
by the ordeal already
scp-682 was sedated and returned to its
containment chamber without incident
where it regenerated back to its default
state things weren't so easy with
SCP-173 while a team transported it back
to its containment chamber there was a
power outage in the hall and things went
dark and considering as cp-173 in
addition to the sculpture and the peanut
could also be nicknamed instant Killing
Spree just add Darkness it won't
surprise you to hear there were no
survivors 173 killed everyone in the
hall then escaped out into the wider
facility causing a site-wide Containment
Breach and a huge number of casualties
the cause of the electrical short that
kick-started this massacre was traced
back to Dr shenron's tampering with the
incinerator system this got the doctor
formally reprimanded stripped of his
titles and his memories and relieved of
his duty but the worst was still very
much to come for everyone involved
including
scp-682 because the true terrifying
potential of SCP-173 was soon going to
be Unleashed and when that happened
nowhere would be safe on what was
otherwise a very normal day in a very
normal procedure when a few d-classes
were sent into SCP-173 cell something
extraordinary and terrible happened
SCP-173 multiplied like a single cell
organism undergoing mitosis 173 somehow
just split into two equal copies of
itself two d-classes were killed in this
first duplication event but they were
just the beginning soon enough people
would look back so fondly on the days
when there were only a mere two of these
things the foundation and 682 for all
their disagreements are very much alike
both are always vying for control over
their situations and both achieve this
through understanding and adapting to
whatever is threatening them as SCP-173
continued to multiply the foundation did
what they could to adapt and regain
control they tried to contain specific
instances in smaller containment units
they tried to create new methods for
permanent observation they even tried
shipping them off to the moon but none
of it did any good
SCP-173 continued to duplicate they
escaped began spreading further they
killed half a million civilians in 48
hours and believe us when we tell you
they were just getting started the
ever-growing army of 173 instances went
on massive killing sprees every night
taking out huge swaths of the civilian
population as they scrambled and
panicked in the dark and they weren't
just going after civilians evidently
much like 682 173 had a grudge against
the SCP Foundation for all those Decades
of imprisonment the 173 Army began
locating surrounding and destroying
entire Foundation containment sites and
killing off all the staff and the
anomalies inside of all the entities in
containment that might one day go EXT
okay and destroy the world as we know it
not many people had 173 on their bingo
card if only they've listened to 682's
warnings and reallocated their
termination resources to 173 things may
have turned out differently and speaking
of our scaly old foe 682 sat in an empty
chamber had been days since anyone had
come in to check on it all fled or dead
from snapped necks one of the two he
thought about escaping containment but
given the bloodbaths going on outside
all the time what would even be the
point all that was really left was time
and that was a rapidly depleting
resource he just needed to wait for that
thing to come and see him again
scp-682 blinked and there it was
standing before him looking blink and
there was more blink so many of them so
so many blink surrounded on all sides by
that terrible creature too many to fight
too many to win just waiting watching
mocking him there was only one thing
left to do blink hello everyone if
you're a fan of SCP explained you'll
know that we regularly post interesting
questions in our community tab asking
for responses from you are dear fans
these have ranged from questions about
specific anomalies like scp-096 or your
suggestions on how we should actually
kill
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
we've even asked you which anomalous
Powers you'd want to have and pose your
questions directly to scp-343 also known
as God and of course the terrifying and
Infamous Scarlet King but in our latest
Community question asking you about
hypothetical crossovers between the SCP
Foundation and the weird wild Multiverse
of all fiction you truly outdid yourself
with thousands upon thousands of
responses and we thought rather than
just making one video selecting our
favorites we turn each of our favorites
into whole videos and how are we going
to do that that's where this wonderful
state-of-the-art Gizmo comes into play
you may remember the animatron 6000 are
incredibly Advanced artificial
intelligence driven supercomputer
designed specifically to run simulations
for the SCP Foundation we fed this
computer data from countless SCP
Foundation experiments and cross-tests
and all the data from your suggestions
this will allow the fine folks at the
SCP Foundation to explore any anomalous
hypothetical without risking the lives
of Staff members or civilians this
brings us to our first simulation
suggested in a huge number of comments
could scp-682 be contained within the
back rooms for those not in the know the
back rooms is an internet urban legend
that spiraled into a full-blown
phenomenon it's built on the premise
that if you're not careful and enter
certain specific circumstances you can
no clip out of our reality and enter a
terrifying multi-level alternate reality
we are stalked by a variety of bizarre
and frightening creatures this could be
a complete nightmare for your average
person but how would it play out if
scp-682 the endlessly angry hard to
destroy reptile found its way inside
also for another backrooms related
surprise stick around until the end of
the video in the meantime though let's
boot up the animatron and test this new
scenario the worst had happened again
scp-682 had busted out of containment
during a cross test and started making a
beeline for the nearest populated area
several helicopters containing heavily
armed MTF new seven hammer down members
were in Hot Pursuit attempting to slow
The Vicious reptile down with targeted
sniper fire at its legs but it seems
that these efforts were all for naught
scp-682 had already reached the defunct
industrial district on the edge of a
nearby City and if the Beast managed to
actually reach a populated area
all hell would break loose that's when
they pulled out the heavy Weaponry
miniguns mounted to the helicopters
Unleashed A Reign of Hellfire down onto
scp-682 however 682 managed to dodge
most of the bullets and simply tank the
rest command authorized the use of heavy
ornaments the helicopter's missile
launchers they pick up the pieces
afterwards once scp-682 was back in
containment however the reptile had
plans of its own it charged into a
nearby abandoned chemical plant to avoid
the gunfire from above this was exactly
what hammerdown wanted the helicopters
circled around the chemical plant and
Unleashed a barrage of powerful
incendiary missiles blowing the plant to
Kingdom come in hopes of dragging an
incapacitated 682 out of the rubble
afterwards but when the smoke had
cleared and only the rubble was left 682
was nowhere to be seen even for the
hardcore operatives of hammerdown this
caused an anxiety Spike had a tunnel
into the ground had it adapted to the
attack by turning invisible or getting
tiny to escape they'd done all these
things before or after all the deranged
attempts at putting scp-682 in the
ground had some light firebombing killed
the monster whatever the case they need
to search in case scp-652 popped up
somewhere else and started causing Havoc
if it was still alive which it probably
was they couldn't rest on their Laurels
until they'd found it again meanwhile
scp-682 woke up it felt groggy and
irritated its body resting against an
unpleasant soggy carpet it licked the
carpet the moisture had the distinct
flavor of human spinal fluid which 682
had tasted many times before the sickly
yellow walls and incessant buzzing from
the fluorescent lights up above were
nauseating and it gave 682 a nagging
headache this only made 682's default
emotionless rage and hatred even worse
they began walking around exploring this
strange spatial anomalous environment
was this more of that frustrating
Foundation trickery another one of those
purile cross-tests the last thing 682
remembered was running at one of the
walls in the chemical plant a wall that
in hindsight seemed darker than all the
others but rather than shattering
through the brickwork it was here now in
this strange tacky Lobby that never
seemed to end it was like a kaleidoscope
of Mt 1990s office Kitsch endless
worthless yellow walls arranged like
some Labyrinthian nonsensical maze
leading nowhere and devoid of all life
as scp-682 wandered through it and of
course
scp-682 found it disgusting it was only
on level zero and already 682 hated the
back rooms just as much as it hated R
Dimension someone or something had to
pay for the crime of inconveniencing it
this way and it would happily turn this
whole dimension inside out just to find
some beings to kill inside it yes that
would be great fun
scp-682 began its frantic search for an
exit evolving an innate sonar ability
and picking up speeds that would be
impossible for human beings this is the
part where most people would go mad or
die from Hunger or thirst
scp-682 not so much it could keep
searching and searching and searching
until the Stars burned out in the sky it
would find its prey somehow and when it
did it would put them through hell and
as it turned out this new universe
rewarded 682's dog's stubbornness
because when it passed through a
seemingly random hallway after hours of
searching it was in a different place
entirely this place looked like some
huge abandoned warehouse complex with
water shining off the ground if 682 had
more advanced knowledge of the back
rooms he would have known this was level
one but the only number scp-682 cared
about was body count and in that regard
it would find level one to be a vast
Improvement two groups of humans had
established bases in this level of the
back rooms the major Explorer group a
faction of professional backrooms
Travelers who maintained their base
Alpha on this level and the back room's
non-aligned trade group a commercial
group whose primary base is an economic
Hub on this very level a Fortified
city-like Area with a population of 412
which would a few hours after 682's
appearance be a population of zero but
before all of that it felt like grabbing
a bite at the diner Tom's Diner is a
refuge for many people trapped in the
back rooms a casual Eatery nestled into
the coal Warehouse environment of level
1 where people could get a warm meal
from Tom a former cook who's been
trapped in the back room for years
scp-682 was eager to be part of this
Grand tradition but the hard to destroy
reptile decided to Buck the trend a
little by just devouring Tom himself
from there decided to launch its rage
fueled offensive against the various
humanoid inhabitants of the level both
the major explore group base Alpha and
the back room's non-aligned trade Group
trade keep were heavily fortified
against the kind of entities these folks
had gotten used to facing in the back
rooms but they were completely
unprepared for a creature of
scp-682's sheer power intelligence
endurance and ferocity the SCP
Foundation had been studying the
creature for decades with far more
resources than either of these two
backrooms-bound groups and they still
had a hard time keeping the Beast
consistently contained sadly for the
great Bastion of human hope in the back
rooms
scp-682 swept through both outposts in a
matter of hours killing everyone there
without an ounce of remorse the only
person there it took its time with was
the final human being left in the
decimated remains of the major explorers
group base Alpha it grabbed the man by
the throat and squeezed asking with its
guttural growling voice
[Music]
fear the Explorer told 682 that he had
never heard of the SCP Foundation nor
did he know what kind of entity 682 was
then what is this place tell me and I
might give you a quick death the
Explorer gave as good a response as he
could 682 was trapped in the back rooms
a multi-level interdimensional nightmare
filled with dangerous creatures that
made 682 curious dangerous creatures
that could make an interesting challenge
682 asked the Explorer how could access
these other levels and find these
creatures and the Explorer explained
that through exploring these levels
enough anyone could no clip into the
next one it really was that simple with
that 682 knew all it needed to know and
carelessly murdered the final human
being of level one it had killed so many
humans over its long and twisted life it
was no different from breathing air now
and utterly perfunctory action it was
eager to discover these other creatures
on the lower levels and teach them a new
level of fear they'd never experienced
682 stormed the Halls until it achieved
the next successful no clip into level 2
which manifested as a series of old
dilapidated maintenance tunnels that
seemed to stretch on for millions of
miles wonderful there were humans here
too apparently but who cared about them
this was the first level to feature a
smorgasbord of entities ripe for The
Killing It sped through the tunnels
teeth and fangs born eager to deal death
with gleeful abandon the first entities
it encountered in the expansive tunnels
of level 2 were a collection of beings
known as crawlers insect-like creatures
infected with an extremely aggressive
fungal growth just getting close to them
could present an active risk to humans
not so much for a creature that could
easily regenerate after being tossed
into the Sun as the creatures tried to
Lunge
scp-682 simply crushed and devoured them
with little effort they tasted a little
stale on account of a fungus but the
chewiness was pleasing hopefully there
would be more challenging foes down in
the tunnel than these mere insects
scp-682 thought to itself while
journeying deeper into the endless
network of tunnels soon enough as cp682
ventured into a section of the tunnel
engulfed in total darkness its eyes
quickly adjusted developing Immaculate
night vision that's when it spotted
another creature sharing this little
slice of Darkness with it a pair of
floating glowing eyes an almost
cartoonish teeth grinning like some
maniacal Looney Tune this is an entity
known as a Smiler and they're a
terrifying threat to any humans
venturing through the back rooms
scp-682 wasn't impressed it began a
perfect adaptation for the situation its
body began to Glow emitting incredible
levels of both heat and light carving
through the darkness of the tunnel and
causing The Smiler to emit a terrible
Pierce shriek the sheer heat of this new
ability melted sections of the level 2
tunnels around
scp-682 when the light finally dimmed
down to slightly more reasonable levels
where The Smiler once stood was instead
a fizzling black Scorch Mark another
creature had painfully bitten the dust
and scp-682 was starting to have some
fun it took off further down into the
tunnels looking forward to finding its
next victim sadly for scp-682 it
wouldn't get to kill the next set of
victims a group of four child face limbs
spooky faceless little girls who like to
cut apart their typical human victims
with small objects were wading a little
further down the pipe however when they
felt scp-682 approaching they almost
sensed the power and cruelty of the
Beast coming towards them even being
little monsters themselves game
recognized game and they knew that they
needed to get the hell out of there
before the monster arrived they climbed
between the pipes on the tunnel walls
and skid off into hiding places deep in
the dark lucky for them
scp-682 passed them and just kept going
what would be the point in wasting time
on these little morsels when there were
apparently so many other creatures to
Massacre down here next scp-682 came
across a truly pathetic creature
something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even
interacting with it was a creature known
as a clump a strange bundle of living
limbs that will move at Great speeds and
attack its usually human targets to try
to do the same to scp-682 maniacally
flailing its many Twisted limbs 682
killed it in a single Stomp and moved on
filling its own psychological equivalent
of pity but not that much of it not long
after mercy killing the clump
scp-682 came face to face with a series
of hounds mutant humanoids who travel on
all fours behaving in a wolf-like
fashion this would of course be the
stuff of nightmares for your average
human being but would far more more
likely put a being like the hard to
destroy reptile to sleep with sheer
boredom humans acting like dogs that
makes them even more worthless the
creature thought as it charged forwards
and began tearing the group of hounds to
shreds minutes later it was splitting
off into an adjoining tunnel searching
for more easy entertainment but the
deeper scp-682 made its way into the
bowels of level 2 the more it approached
a truly horrifying realization the
creatures it was slaughtering here were
even more boring than the ones the SCP
Foundation ceaselessly threw at it back
on its native reality or at least the
reality where they'd contained it back
in that world it had faced giant flaming
demigods with swords hotter than the sun
it had faced some pale shrieking
monstrosity that didn't seem to die no
matter what the reptile threw at it
there was the dark gooey old man The
Immortal Warrior from the Black Coffin
and even the all-devouring bunny rabbit
here it was killing the same wretched
selection of beasts again and again a
truly pitiful offering was this really
the best this world had to offer
incidentally the next creature it found
was literally known as wretches by the
human inhabitants of the back rooms they
were fleshy zombie-like creatures that
scp-682 figured the sarcasts back home
might enjoy they couldn't believe that
it was thinking fondly of that old place
while it carved the monsters to ribbons
with its claws it missed its old enemies
like Dr bright Dr claff and even that
irritating yellow blob of snot the more
tried to take its mind off the old world
by killing its way through this Ant Farm
of endless tunnels the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic for example
there were the play goblins impish
little creatures with masks like that of
a plague doctor 682 found itself
thinking almost fondly about
scp-049 while at listlessly ate the tiny
mischievous creatures like a depressed
person binging an extra large pack of
chips even their tiny squeak as they
crunch between the reptile's terrible
teeth gave it no joy what a bleak turn
of events this had all turned out to be
as it wandered through the infinite
tunnels killing creatures and even
humans as it found them
scp-682 made a quiet promise to itself
somehow some way it would make its way
back to the universe it so recently
departed it would leave the back rooms
no matter how many levels a quiet
burning husk and returned to the world
of Fools and fiends that had taken for
granted all this time a visit to the
back rooms had taught the hard to
destroy reptile in All Too Human lesson
sometimes you don't know what you have
until it's gone sure the SCP Foundation
may have tried to kill it in a new
bizarre and increasingly sadistic way
every single day but that variety was
the spice of life it would return home
someday it knew that much but of course
a lot of creatures and people would need
to die before then but if that's what it
took well so be it as
682 licked its dagger-like fangs and
kept crawling another day another failed
attempt at death if scp-682 had anything
even resembling a sense of humor he
might ask for it to be printed on a
motivational poster and stuck to the
side of his containment chamber where he
eternally melts and regrows at the mercy
of high concentration acid they just
cross-tested him with Abel again unlike
some of the others he'd been forced to
face that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn't intelligent enough to fear he'd
always come back just as stupid and
violent this encounter had left the hard
to destroy reptile at 30 percent of his
previous body mass bloody and bashed
he'd survived the encounter he always
survived they brought what was left of
him back to his cell in a forklift a
blasted forklift how could it even be
more humiliating as his eyes star
started to grow back in his head he
could swear he even saw one of the
technicians laughing at him his name tag
read agent Nigel Kelly noted 682 would
specifically hunt down and kill him the
next time he breached of course every
single day he plotted revenge against
the human race along with everything
else but the sum they owed in pain blood
and despair could never be repaid in
full after all every single one of them
except Dr bright could only really die
once they'd brought 682 to the precipice
a thousand times only for his own body
to cheat him and deprive him of the
sweet release of death and if the
foundation had their way it would be
done a thousand times more and they
wouldn't even stop there 682 couldn't
even imagine the number of containment
breaches it would take to deal a blow
even comparable to the one he had faced
all he could do was dream dream of a
reckoning that would turn the tables
something that would plunge Humanity
into the state of constant pain and
Terror that had been all he'd ever known
since these fumbling sadists and white
coats had locked him up here what a
beautiful day that would be little did
scp-682 know that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where scp-682 was kept after
all orders from the o5 council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a site holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents
watched their children laughing and
frolicking in an idyllic playground some
squealed with Glee as they descended the
slide some of the more ambitious Little
Tikes tried to go over the bar on the
swings others waited in line for some
delicious soft serve at a parked ice
cream truck one mother brought an ice
cream cone and walked over to a near by
bench where she began to enjoy her
delicious Frozen treat it was a
remarkably hot day out and a little ice
cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied
you could see the distant air wobbling
in the heat already her ice cream was
starting to melt white rivulets
dribbling down the sides of the cone and
onto her hands suddenly almost
imperceptibly the quality of the light
shifted the kind of thing you'd dismiss
as a trick of the eyes and forget just
as quickly were it not for the
catastrophic effects that were about to
unfold as the woman leaned forward to
liquor melting ice cream something
dripped onto her skirt but as she looked
down she slowly realized that what
dripped onto her wasn't the Pure White
of her ice cream it was the same exact
tone as her skin she felt a terrible
burning sensation all through her body
the most horrible debilitating pain
she'd ever expect experienced like every
cell in her body was screaming and
trying to make a break for it she turned
to the other parents sitting near the
playground they were screaming too each
collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness different parts of their body
falling at different speeds as they
transitioned through states of matter
when they hit the ground they were
taking on a liquid state screaming
worthless boneless blobs the woman even
saw her own arm wilting like a Time
Lapse video of a Dying flower she
dripped and sluiced through the cracks
in the bench until nothing recognizably
human was left only a soggy ice cream
cone sitting uneaten in an instant
billions of Screams rang out over planet
Earth Day had broken things would never
ever be the same again as almost half of
humanity instantaneously took on a
liquid state needless to say with the
most dangerous and far-reaching
anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind
of warning the SCP Foundation was
incredibly busy this would take some
unprecedented action the members of the
o5 council who weren't melted during the
initial blast convened over secure video
link while sequestering themselves
underground in what amounted to multiple
human lifetimes of some of the most high
pressure choices imaginable they made
the most difficult decision since the
very beginning of the SCP Foundation in
the service of all mankind they would
now break the Masquerade the SCP
Foundation would at long last step out
of the Shadows to save the rest of
humanity from the tyranny of the light
broadcasts went out all over the globe
every TV screen every live stream every
radio broadcast was commandeered they
gave instructions based on the scattered
Intel they
for some reason the sun had turned
against them exposure would lead any
biological creatures melting away into
sentient piles of flesh-colored sludge
people would remain indoors and away
from any light sources all windows must
remain covered travel only at night and
even then heavily covered with
protective gear there can only be one
objective for whoever is left make your
way to the nearest SCP Foundation
containment facility and seek Refuge
inside if anyone could figure out the
answer to this terrifying existential
riddle it would be the SCP Foundation
anyone who is exposed should be
considered lost while as always the SCP
Foundation did all they could to project
a sense of control over the situation on
the inside it was pandemonium somehow
despite everything this event had taken
all of them by surprise how could anyone
have predicted that the Cradle of our
Solar System's delicate living balance
would suddenly become a grinder a huge
number of foundation operatives were
wiped out in the initial exposure Global
Communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to
scp-682 as another evil tactician once
put it chaos was a ladder from the
inside of his acid tank 6av2 could sense
the fear and pain suddenly exuding from
his surrounding environment it was
greater than ever before what was
happening out there this was no average
Containment Breach something was really
really happening out there 682 began to
adapt and finally attune its hearing
until could pick up the chatter from
outside maybe we can convert some of the
d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh God oh God we've lost sight seven
sight 10 site 23 site 40 site 52 uh
death toll looks to be in the billions
well we don't know if they're dead
technically but there sure as hell not
human anymore oh this is the big one
this is it XK class even 2000 is
unaccounted for is of that crazy that
they think we're fighting the freaking
Sun needless to say 682's curiosity was
piqued anything that could light a fire
under the foundation like this was
something he could enjoy and with his
impressively strategic intellect he
intuited that a time of great Strife for
the foundation would be the perfect time
to breach containment because whenever
there's violence fear and Chaos on a
mass scale
scp-682 will be there causing it 682
began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful
alkaline substance little by little the
alkaline neutralized the acids
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely froze
around him the ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment unit busting
the rivets of the metal frame and
shattering the reinforced glass with
this goal achieved 682 raised his
internal temperatures to incredible
highs melting the ice around him once
again he was free and ready for some
good old-fashioned Carnage and Mayhem
perhaps he could get a better handle on
this strange new situation too it was
all rather exciting just a girl with
goals huh SCP Foundation Personnel were
already running around like ants trying
desperately to avoid the caustic laser
beam of the magnifying glass you can
only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall Kool-Aid man's style and began
to ruthlessly Massacre everyone around
him just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 Containment
Breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular Containment
Breach was that give even the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran into
682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who dared to get
in this way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed in bit and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
believe leaving great piles of bodies in
his wake all the while he was pondering
the things he heard those Foundation
drones saying something about the Sun
and an XK class scenario
interesting 682 also observed that any
apertures that could potentially allow
light into the facility had also been
shuttered perhaps they weren't
overreacting this time like they always
did with him maybe they were dealing
with some kind of phenomenon that would
now pass this wretched world and those
who lived in it into the void wouldn't
that be A fitting karmic fate for them
all still 682's bloodlust didn't
outweigh his logic he needed to know
more about the situation before
proceeding and in this maybe he could
kill two Foundation birds with one stone
elsewhere in the building alarms flared
the air was suffused with panicked
voices and frequent screams nobody knew
what was going on not really they'd only
gotten details here and there and the
details they'd received were terrifying
all their families and loved ones
outside probably gone so many of the
people in so much of the world they'd
been fighting for risking it all for had
disappeared in an instant carried to
Hell on a ray of sunshine why were they
still here was this horror not truly
uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent Nigel
Kelly as he stood alone in this office
us almost catatonic he'd had his friends
and family on the outside all likely
reduced to those horrible fleshy blobs
he was alone in the world risking his
life for nothing how could this get any
worse his mind kept repeating that
question again and again and again and
the universe gave him an answer in the
form of a deep reptilian voice saying
into his ear from behind he turned with
a shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee or reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
Furious Beast 682 reached out with a
massive quad hand and grabbed him by the
Torso lifting him up into the air the
creature was gripping so tight that he
could feel his ribs starting to crack
the monster hissed
do I see you at the time to tell jokes
do you feel like laughing now agent
Kelly begged and pleaded for his life
fighting for his next breath from the
crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent Kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
higher-ups were calling this
scp-001 when day breaks the sun had gone
Rogue somehow and being in contact with
any kind of sunlight would now cause
people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying living sludge and it wasn't
just people the condition also affected
anomalies and interestingly it appeared
to negate all previous anomalous effects
so 682's out of additional ability may
not even save it if it was exposed he
told 682 everything he knew are you are
you gonna let me live agent Kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682's terrible maw
Twisted into What Might Have Been a
Smile
he said with unsettling Joy
[Music]
a terrible scream emanated from the
agent's office if one good thing could
be said for what happened to agent Kelly
that day at least he didn't live long
enough to see the ravages of the
terrible son first hand 682 began to
formulate a plan he took agent Kelly's
wristwatch and integrated it into his
body so he'd have a permanent internal
clock it was the middle of summer so the
sun would have reliably set at 9pm and
would likely begin its rise around 5am
it would be relatively easy to avoid the
sun All Things Considered for lack of a
more eloquent way to put it when it
comes to adapting to new threats
scp-682 is Simply Built different after
slaughtering a few other members of SCP
Foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began enacting the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carapace
and his front set of Limbs began to grow
his muscles bulging and his claw laws
growing the tips turning into Sharp flat
Scoops with sudden and tremendous Force
682 began boring his way into the ground
tunneling clawing through concrete and
dirt with absolute ease normally the SCP
Foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture
him but during the endless horrors of
the breaking day he had carte blanche to
escape and live it up in the ruins of
this rapidly Dying World eventually 682
had poured his way into a roomy sewer
pipe the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the SCP
Foundation had been yet to account for
while they knew that those melted by the
Rogue Sun were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering but the foundation didn't know
was that these former humans were incred
dangerous in their own right The sun
hadn't just irreparably warped their
bodies it had also irreparably warped
their minds it has enslaved them made
them zealots acolytes they developed the
instinct to coagulate into giant
flushing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose of finding victims
and dragging them into the light where
they too could be converted into these
terrible fleshy creatures and add to the
masses they were the Rogue Sun's boots
on the ground metaphorically speaking
and now they were the foundation's
greatest Challenge and getting a handle
on this situation again before it was
just encouraging people to avoid the sun
now the sun was actively trying to
increase its exposure but 682 who was
having a relaxing evening not being
melted for once down in the sewers
couldn't care less he was having the
most calming few hours he'd had in years
he waited checking the time making sure
that it would be dark before he began
tunneling back up to the surface world
he surfaced in the middle of this city
miles away from the foundation facility
he'd spent so many decades being
tortured in he tasted the cool night air
and observed the Desolation that had
been wrought all around him buildings
were on fire cars were crashed and
overturned the ground was cracked
garbled SCP Foundation public service
announcements played to nobody in the
broken display Windows of electronic
stores giant wads of human flesh roamed
slithering around searching for new
victims one notice 682 and began to
approach him gibbering madly in a chorus
of strange voices the hard to destroy
reptile wasted no time in attacking it
tore apart most of the Hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks the
form may have been different but it
still tasted like human flesh and and
scp-682 savored every bite it would be
so simple these Blobs of idiotic flesh
were so easy to kill and there would be
so many terrified humans in this
devastated World hiding away in Dark
Places holding out the hope that maybe
they could reach the safety of a
foundation facility 682 chuckled at the
very thought foolish hope would drown in
an endless well of black and caustic
despair he would find them he would rest
underground in the day and then hunt
them in the dark they would all die
screaming bloodying his claws and fangs
nothing and nobody would stop him he
looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little louder
[Music]
it was just delightful another day
another failed attempt to execute
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile the most recent attempt was
scp-272 an old iron nail with the
ability to pin people's Shadows to the
ground and tear them to shreds when
different configurations of light makes
their Shadows go Haywire just when it
seemed like 272 and a high-powered disco
ball might be the thing to win the
foundation's war against the
misanthropic lizard it did what it
always did pulled out a trump card and
ruined everything its body evolved a
sudden intense bioluminescence that
completely eliminated the beast's Shadow
by overpowering all other light sources
in the room this not only rendered the
foundation strobe lights utterly useless
but blinded several members of d-class
personnel who were sent in to check on
the Beast during testing this resulted
predictably in another big fat L for the
SCP Foundation 682 to 435 Foundation
zero and nobody was more frustrated than
Dr samet samet was a foundation
greenhorn with big Ambitions like every
jerk at the office he was less concerned
with doing his job right and far more
concerned with climbing the corporate
ladder Summit had done all he could cozy
up to site directors and even the
overseers far above all with the goal of
someday getting a seat at their high
table but as any SCP fans know they're
not just giving out positions on or just
under the o5 council to swing something
like that you need to really make an
impression you need to wow them and what
would be a better way to do that than
being the person who killed scp-682
surely if he had actually buried that
Beast they'd hand him the keys to the
proverbial Castle so Dr samet had done
everything he could to get reassigned to
the 682 termination effort and only now
was he realizing just how in over his
head he truly was Dr Simon needed help
from a higher power if you have ever
hoped of beating scp-682 the man needed
God on his side thankfully they just so
happen to have God chilling out in his
containment cell in site 17. perhaps
through enlisting the help of Earth's
Divine Arbiter he could bring an end to
the scourge of scp-682 and Rocket
himself to success in the process
however while Dr Summit may have been
arrogant he wasn't completely delusional
he knew he didn't have the standing to
address scp-343 directly much less to
ask him for a hand in destroying
scp-682 he'd need a go-between someone
with tenure someone who commanded
respect among SCP Foundation staff as
well as the very anomalies they governed
perhaps someone who was a little bit
anomalous themselves and who better fits
this description than the living legend
Dr Jack Bright Dr samit had of course
read the doctor's Personnel files
everybody at the foundation knew about
Dr Bright's exploits from what he's done
to the various things he isn't allowed
to do which we'll cover in a future
video he's also dug up the scp-963 files
the anomalous Medallion keeping Dr
bright alive whether he likes it or not
while a discussion of the exact nature
of The Medallion isn't something you'd
want to have in front of Dr bright
himself after all it is a touchy subject
you could make the argument that The
Medallion is the real him it is where
his soul is condemned to spend perhaps
the rest of Eternity killing and
stealing the body of anyone or anything
that touched it he'd become an immortal
parasite destined to take the finite
lives of others while his own marches on
forever remind you of anyone Dr samet
got into contact with Dr bright and
explained his plan with Bright's hell
he'd recruit scp-343 and bring the very
wrath of God down onto the hard to
destroy reptile of course while Dr samit
naturally assumed himself to be the
smartest person in the room Dr bright
had a more realistic assessment of the
ambitious Young Turks skills he saw Sam
not for what he truly was a climber a
butt kisser a greedy power-hungry
bureaucrat wearing a lab coat and he
thought that made him a researcher
it was laughable what Dr bright found
less funny though was Dr samet's
insistence on calling him
scp-963 there's a lot to know about Dr
bright but one thing you should
definitely commit to memory is that you
should never under any circumstances
call Dr bright as CP 963 and if you were
forever entwined with a necklace that
doomed you to watch everyone you know
and love age and die while depriving you
of that same release you'd probably
resent being associated with it too Dr
bright did agree to participate in Dr
samet's hair brain termination scheme
but with a warning that he did not give
lightly if ever Dr samet called him 963
again he would have one of his own loyal
team members nicknamed The Lucky Bunch
for their High survival rate compared to
other Foundation research teams shoot
him in the foot Dr bright steeled
himself and entered 343's containment
cell where the playful deity had taken
the form of the late comedian George
Burns complete with his trademark
glasses and half smoked stogie they made
small talk with 343 delivering his usual
high-handed cryptic Parables about his
plans for Dr bright and everybody else
he even momentarily teased the idea of
freeing him from his curse but Dr bright
knew better than to buy into these fairy
tales he talked scp-343 into a
cross-test but didn't tell him it was
with 682 or that he was expected to
terminate it that was better left as a
surprise Dr samet and Dr bright stood in
the observation area outside the
cross-testing chamber samit was giddy
with excitement and confidence in this
new experiment Dr Bright's reactions
were a hell of a lot more measured he'd
been working at the foundation long
enough now to know that terminating
scp-682 was a Fool's errand the only
researchers still intent on trying it
were doing so out of stubbornness and
ego and when 343 and 682 were released
into the chamber Dr Bright's healthy
pessimism was more than Justified 682
attacked a nearby door attempting to
breach contain while 343 looked around
confused and seemingly unable to see
anything when he was ordered to kill 682
he was shocked to learn 682 was even in
the room he stormed off moments later in
a huff saying he's not one of mine deal
with him yourself
Dr Bryant was unsurprised Dr Summit was
shocked and Furious how could this have
failed they literally had God on their
side this setback would seriously
compromise his chances of rising through
the ranks unless he found a quick way to
make the best out of a bad situation and
safe face without even thinking he
turned to Dr Brighton said fine it
didn't work doesn't matter get yourself
ready 963 you're going in so it was
decided Dr bright himself would face off
with scp-682 in
scp-343's place Dr bright was a betting
man he loved a good game of chance and
he estimated that his odds of succeeding
were exceptionally low but what would be
the point in refusing even if he
couldn't kill scp-682 perhaps he would
get lucky and the reptile would kill him
instead so many enticing possibilities
Dr bright left to prepare for the coming
battle and because nobody would say that
Dr bright wasn't a man of his word he
had one of his assistants shoot Dr samet
in the foot a few days later Dr bright
Dr samet now in a wheelchair while he
recovered from his unfortunate foot
injury and a collection of other
researchers including Dr Sophia light
were convened in a conference room
planning out their assault on scp-682 a
mechanical staff of sorts was laying on
the table in front of him a kind of
powerful taser capable of firing out
painful bolts of electricity it would be
the only object Dr bright carried into
the chamber with him that day but only
as a way of getting 682's attention not
as a weapon the true weapon was
scp-963 the plan was simple
scp-682 would eat Dr bright and the
power of scp-963 would destroy it from
within as anyone with an awareness of
963's anomalous properties could tell
you for most living beings Touching The
Medallion results in immediate brain
death followed by the consciousness of
Dr bright inhabiting your mindless body
if they could get this phenomenon to
work for scp-682 2. perhaps with Dr
Bright's mind in scp-682's body could
they now end the life of this wretched
Beast once and for all like with all
matters involving scp-682 and Dr bright
it was most likely not going to be so
simple when Dr bright entered the test
chamber with 682 as Dr samet and the
others watch from the observation room
the results were sudden and violent Dr
bright Zapped the monster with his
Electro staff and it came charging for
him a terrible Fury of teeth and Claws
Dr bright had died so many times and yet
he couldn't even recall many experiences
more unpleasant than this and as 682's
interior flesh met
scp-963 Dr bright woke up in the middle
of a strange new place there was a man
standing over him that looked oddly
familiar except for the strange
chainmail habrick he was wearing when Dr
bright found his feet he recognized the
man it was a d-class in fact the first
body he'd ever inhabited after his soul
fused with scp-963 but he wasn't alone
here there were so many people all of
them wearing the same chainmail and
carrying the same electrostats that Dr
bright had carried into the chamber with
him little by little he recognized every
single one of the faces they were all
people whose bodies he'd taken whose
lives he'd cut short to further his own
he looked around and saw more bizarre
sights a grand Castle structured like a
deranged Escher painting and up above
drowning out the sky was a great
reptilian Behemoth like scp-682 on
steroids made entirely from barbecue
sauce the d-class broke The Surreal news
none of this was real it was a fantasy
his mind had concocted to help him cope
with his Consciousness bonding with
scp-682 a more palatable way of
perceiving his new reality and if he
ever wanted to get out and be himself
again he would need need to fight and
conquer the Beast Within Dr bright
joined forces with his past victims
including one former level two
researcher Damien Smith together using
their Electro staffs bright and his army
of mental constructs blasted the great
monster in the sky from the safe
confines of the castle however things
weren't quite as safe as Dr bright had
first imagined the massive creature
descended upon them tearing the castle
to shreds with its huge claws the
construct of Damon Smith was devoured in
the process Dr Bright's brief illusion
of victory was soon stifled by one
immutable fact you could not defeat
scp-682 he retreated from the monster
into the darkness of his own Nightmares
From there he woke up Dr bright was in a
hospital bed The Medallion attached to a
new body after 682's body had rejected
it he was greeted by Dr Sophia light and
a member of the o5 council Dr bright had
effectively been gone for days when he
asked what happened on the outside he
was told that 682 had entered a 36-hour
coma before growing massive Claws and
tunneling out of containment where it
caused a massive breach though strangely
upon breaking out of the chamber it only
attacked one researcher and in unrelated
news Dr samet had been taken off the 682
case it didn't take long for things to
return to normal for Dr bright well as
normal as life can be when you're a man
as strange as him but while few would
notice it 682 was left altered it had
taken a souvenir from Dr bright
fragments of the consciousness of Damon
Smith it felt his pain his fear it
tasted it dissected it and now
understood it and when the opportunity
presented itself once more as it always
did he couldn't wait to inflicted on
others Abel wandered through the Sands a
lone Warrior dragging a Long Dark Sword
behind him his black cloak flowing in
the gentle breeze the sword was thirsty
it had been too long since it tasted
blood what had it been a day since he
cut down 10 men in a Tavern without
breaking a sweat they bled and screamed
like pigs as he diced them into bloody
chunks he couldn't remember their faces
they hadn't earned that very few
combatants had been remarkable enough to
Warrant committing to memory it was all
just more dead flesh he took a sip from
his canteen inside did this world hold
no more challenges what a boring
eternity was laying out before him his
burden as The Greatest Warrior of all
time weighed on him heavier than the
chain it was old and Rusty levered over
his shoulder and grasped in one bloody
hand about 15 feet behind him the chain
was connected to a dark stone
sarcophagus that was as much a part of
him as his eyes skin or heart if ever he
was slain in the glory heat of battle
he'd rise out of it ready to fight and
kill another day all because of the
actions of his worthless good for
nothing brother he looked up when he
heard the rush of footsteps and the
clanking of armor Warriors or whatever
pass for them around here about 20 of
them circled all around him yes oh yes
his grip tightened around his sword one
of the Warriors called out something
about him being under arrest by order of
the king for murders Beyond counting
Abel couldn't help but yawn words words
words why even bother her he dropped the
chain and in one fluid motion he threw
his sword in a fraction of a second it
pierced the armor of the chattering man
spearing him through his formerly
Beating Heart the scream died in his
throat he fell to his knees then
collapsed entirely the other soldiers
sent to kill or apprehend him turned to
their Fallen leader in gasp it was that
little gasp that moment of distraction
that sealed their Fates Abel's face
cracked into a whisper of a grin as he
drew two long daggers from the darkness
of his coat he'd at least try to have
fun with this before the others could
even get over their Leader's sudden
death Abel had vaulted forward and begun
his delicate dance of Slaughter every
swing found its way through armor and
into skin he sliced throats cleaved off
heads parried blows and pierced Hearts
there was barely a single scream Abel
killed too quick for screams in what
would seem like the blink of an eye for
some the soldiers around Abel fell most
dead the rest dying some looked up to
him in their dying moments in terrified
awe of the efficacy of their killer in
their dying moments they knew that they
never had a chance they might as well
have been facing the glistening Scythe
of death himself on the battlefield Abel
on the other hand rolled his eyes inside
another aesthetic waste of time he
sensed movement in the corner of his eye
one of the wounded soldiers was limping
to his feet trying to use the sword to
lever himself off of the ground with a
flick of each wrist Abel tossed his
knives into the man killing him
instantly it really was that easy your
attempt to kill me does not offend me he
said to whoever was still able to hear
what offends me is that they would send
so few and that those few would be such
pitiful excuses for soldiers this wasn't
a battle it was a mercy killing he was
ready to turn around grab the chain and
carry on walking when he felt a sudden
pain in his back there was a slight
whistle then another sharp Spike of pain
there were now two arrows sticking out
of his back Abel turned surprised and
saw a much larger Force standing behind
him Swordsmen archers men with clubs and
axes and chains the ones he'd kill were
little more than distraction this was
the real threat this was a real army
perhaps these fools would give him some
actual exercise he reached into his
cloak and pulled out a mighty obsidian
battle ax at the very least he tried to
have a little fun turning this fighting
force into cold cuts a fog of arrows
sailed through the air as he charged
forwards Perforating his body but the
injuries didn't slow him down he lunge
slashed and cleaved even as the weapon
struck him he carried on killing person
after person at times it was almost
exciting almost but not quite by the
time he was done none were left standing
30 arrows were sticking out of him he'd
been cut deep by more weapons than he
could count on his fingers and toes he
was breathing deeply scarred chest
pumping up and down he coughed blood and
cracked his neck back into place they
might have cut him a little too deep
this time no matter Abel fell to his
knees feel feeling the life draining
from him he wondered when he awoke from
the coffin again what the world would
look like sometimes it was days
sometimes weeks months or even years as
he fell forward dying once again he'd
hoped that he'd wake into a world with a
warrior or beast that could actually
challenge him maybe someday this was one
of Abel's many lives hundreds of years
before he was contained by the SCP
Foundation he's perhaps The Greatest
Warrior who ever lived died and lived
again he's a man so individually deadly
that not only is he kept in a
containment chamber Under the Sea
surrounded by highly trained and armored
guards he has his own localized on-site
nuclear weapon ready to blow away and
annihilate him and his entire
containment area if deemed necessary he
may not be a contagious anomalous
pathogen or a lethal memetic Hazard or a
giant Beast shooting World destroying
Fireballs in every direction but if this
one-man Massacre was left to his own
devices there's no doubt that he would
methodically Slaughter his way through
the human race until an XK Class end of
the world scenario was practically
inevitable he was fueled by pure hatred
and an almost bottomless bloodlust he
simply lived to fight and kill and not
only did he have the will and the skill
to be a pure force of annihilation but
his anomalous abilities also make him
perfectly tailored to the task he has
massively enhanced physical strength
speed and durability taking the kind of
damage that would kill several normal
humans to reliably put him down though
even that is only a temporary measure
Abel will always resurrect back into his
black sarcophagus to Menace the SCP
Foundation another day it is also
effectively impossible to disarm Abel
because he has the anomalous ability to
pull deadly edged weapons from localized
pocket Dimensions at will and his
proficiency with these weapons is unlike
any Warrior the world has ever known
before or since during containment
breaches he's regularly killed scores of
trained Foundation guards with both
numerical advantages and considerably
more advanced ranged weapons despite
being a simple humanoid he was taking up
a truly insane amount of containment
resources despite his violent tendencies
Abel is still a recognizable sentient
human albeit an extremely deadly
anomalous one this led some higher-ups
at the foundation to come up with an
interesting idea what if Abel's Eternal
rage could be harnessed what if they
could use their resources to reshape
this rampaging killer into a devoted
sword of the foundation's cause after
all if he wanted worthy opponents what
could be more worthy than the anomalous
monsters that the foundation faced on a
daily basis and as long as they kept the
sarcophagus even if Abel was killed in
the line of duty he'd still be accounted
for in many ways if he could be trained
and truly brought to heal there could be
no better asset to their coming struggle
it was this logic allowing anomalies to
work for the SCP Foundation in exchange
for benefits that led to the creation of
a new groundbreaking mobile task force
MTF
omega-7 pen Pandora's Box this group
became the SCP foundation's Hail Mary
pass for any particularly dangerous or
potentially deadly missions they could
send in able along with a group of
highly trained Foundation soldiers that
even the ancient blade wielding Warrior
held respect for while like their
namesake Pandora's Box it would all wind
up in terrible tragedy to begin with
they achieved some of the highest
mission successful results of any mobile
task force on the foundation's payroll
no task was too challenging for them to
swoop in and crush it this was far from
expected able one of the most violent
scps they've ever contained suddenly
became a great asset to their operations
a vital tool in their quest to keep the
anomalous at Bay he cleaved through
Legions of chaos Insurgency soldiers
during breaches into their secure sites
he fought off well-paid well-trained and
well-armed Bodyguards of Marshall Carter
and dark limited during Foundation raids
on their clandestine operations he'd
even gone Toe to Toe with some some of
the deadliest anomalies in containment
during mass escapes it was hard to
imagine how they'd ever lived without
him of course while Abel was happier
than he had been in years in his element
in fact as a working Warrior giving
varied missions and frequent opponents
there was still something nagging at him
his thoughts were hounded by his white
whale the endless search for a truly
worthy opponent someone or something
that could really give him a run for his
money after Millennia of leaving
opponents dead in this wake nothing
would bring him more joy than meeting
someone that actually knocked him on his
ass a new bar somewhere above him to
work towards oh what a glorious day that
would be eventually the foundation
started to run into a problem they were
running out of missions to give Abel
after all he wasn't the kind of
operative you could just give any
mission to his potential for collateral
damage was truly staggering he'd
neutralized the anomaly then Slaughter
everyone within a 100 foot range just to
work off some of the excess energy like
a hand grenade he was powerful but
dangerously imprecise if they ran out of
high priority missions what were they
supposed to do just put Abel back in his
box to gather dust until someone else
rolled around he was getting antsy
enough between missions already that's
when an unexpected member of personnel
stepped forward Dr Jack Bright you see
Dr Brighton Abel had a history and not
an altogether Pleasant one not that
anyone could really have a pleasant
history with Abel Jack was only a junior
researcher when he had his run-in
carrying a seemingly worthless Medallion
dubbed scp-963 back to its containment
Locker that's when a wall next to him
exploded showering him with brick
fragments and dust only to reveal Abel
standing behind the new aperture before
young Dr bright even had a chance to
scream Abel had already cleaved through
him leaving him in two distinct parts
that were both very much dead at least
it seemed that way until it was revealed
that Dr Bright's Consciousness had
actually been eternally bonded with
scp-963 giving him the gift and curse of
immortality since then Dr bright had
become increasingly reckless in his
conduct perhaps hoping that the next
time he Fades to Black the movie that is
his sad Strange Life won't just start to
roll again of course he hasn't been
lucky in that regard yet naturally this
has given Dr bright complex feelings
about his fellow anomalous Foundation
employee so when the call came around
all the senior researchers and site
directors asking if there were any tasks
that Abel seemed fit for he had one very
pressing suggestion after all it wasn't
that long after Dr bright had been
forced into a cross-test with the
intention of terminating 682 which had
not only been a failure but a generally
painful and exhausting experience now
perhaps it would be Abel's turn to take
his lumps he happily put forth a
suggestion claiming that surely the
foundation's new sword wielding Golden
Boy could give the hard to destroy
reptile the old College try after all
even if Abel was killed in the process
he'd just come right back it was a
situation where they really could not
lose so why not take a chance what's the
Worst That Could Happen the o5 council
found Dr Bright's pitch extremely
compelling he succeeded in every Mission
they'd given him so far so perhaps he
could carry that success into the
Herculean task of actually terminating
682 one boundlessly bloodthirsty killer
might be the only thing truly capable of
taking out another of equal magnitude
when Abel was informed with this latest
Mission he got a scary glint in his eye
they gave him warning after warning the
Beast is said to be unkillable it can
adapt to anything it's killed scores of
people and survived the attacks of an
anomalies thought to be Flawless Killers
the more it was explained to him the
more Abel felt the tingling sensation
deep within was this it had he now
discovered the perfect opponent
something that would actually challenge
him would actually put him through his
Paces yes yes yes
he accepted the mission without question
Abel would fight
scp-682 until his breath was no longer
in order to prepare for the match
scp-682 was released into a secure area
Rocky desert-like terrain boarded on all
sides by a foundation perimeter hundreds
of meters away on all sides they thought
it best for The Showdown to happen here
after all with combatants like Abel and
682 it was bound to make a mess one way
or another Abel Strode with pronounced
Swagger onto the Battleground shortly
afterwards carrying perhaps the most
powerful sword he'd ever summoned it was
somewhere between a claymore and a
chainsaw and Unholy Union that gave the
resulting weapon a degree of deranged
badassery not ever seen on the
battlefields of planet Earth before
carrying this thing Abel felt like a
king and he was about to slay the most
ancient and bestial of monsters as he
approached 682 and took in the whole of
it he could feel his heart pounding with
excitement in his chest it was a huge
reptilian nightmare he could see its
scales hardening into a mighty carapace
as he approached its huge serrated fangs
its bulging sinewing muscles an insane
dagger-like claws oh yes this would be
the one the Beast snarled at him as he
approached he just smiled puffed out his
chest and said I have heard Tales of
creatures like you glorious beasts of
scale and flesh Talon and Fang a prowess
in battle even greater than the immense
intellect hiding behind those beastial
eyes they said your kind once Ruled the
Earth from enormous stockpiles of
treasure killing and eating all who
displeased you but you were knocked from
your throne one by one by the great
warriors who walked this world no longer
until they were no more and you became
but a mere myth even I had thought you
to be nothing but fairy tales but yet
here you stand before me a living dragon
in response to Abel's lofty speech the
monster merely grumbled and shouted him
claiming he was little more than a
pathetic SCP Foundation laptop following
orders and being manipulated it showed
no respect for Abel as a valued enemy
compatant merely another nuisance thrown
at it in a feudal attempt to finish its
wretched and seemingly eternal life Abel
couldn't take such insolence he left
forwards bringing down his mighty
chainsaw Claymore ready to cleave the
beast in two however what he didn't
expect was the move
scp-682 pulled next throwing its head up
against the blade of Abel's sword
shredding away huge chunks of Flesh and
Bone an utterly confusing Abel in the
process for the first time in a lifetime
of intense battles Abel found himself
thinking what the hell am I up against
here the force of 682's headbutt threw
able off balance leaving his stomach
briefly exposed but briefly was all
scp-682 needed it thundered its massive
Stony fist into Abel's gut throwing him
like a ragdoll into a nearby rock with
such a force that it nearly shattered
The Rock behind him it was a force like
he hadn't felt in years he spat some
bloody teeth and grinned this was just
what the doctor ordered he issued a
challenge to the beast in a long dead
language as it seized violently
regenerating growing taking on the Stony
qualities of the ground around it it
looked like a vengeful living Mountain a
true Behemoth of a beast in other words
challenge accepted Abel pulled an
obscenely giant maze from the shadows of
his cloak the handle six feet long with
a chaos of swirling blades and spikes a
perfect weapon for slaying a dragon like
this he thought to himself the two
charged at each other full of power and
fury Abel swung the mace once again
shattering the creature's head and
flinging it back across the battlefield
with the sheer force of its strike the
decimated lizard clawed its way into the
ground devouring the rocks and the Earth
integrating more matter to fuel its
regeneration but it wasn't long before
Abel was upon it again striking
mercilessly giving blows as the monster
gave brutal claw strikes in return they
were ripping each other's bodies apart
piece by piece but Abel felt so
exhilarated he could barely even notice
it was the fight of his life a battle
against a truly worthy opponent this was
Heaven Abel leaped into the air and
Unleashed a volley of deadly chakram
down onto the Beast shredding into its
reinforced flesh as the force of gravity
brought him down he pulled a mighty Ax
from his cloak and bellowed A Warrior's
Roar as he brought it down splattering
into the nightmarish body of
scp-682 however this did nothing to even
slow the Beast Down it flipped over
slashing Abel with its claws when Abel
stumbled it leaped on top of him
unleashing devastating slashes and
punches onto the Fallen warrior with the
speed of a machine gun firing when it
raised its claw to deal with the killing
blow though Abel once again turned the
tables he produced a giant pair of
mechanical scissors from thin air and
sliced off both of
scp-682's four legs the Beast descended
with its Mighty Jaws to devour Abel but
he kicked up with freakish strength
behind his related boot the sheer force
of the kick flipped scp-682 onto its
back now it was Able's turn to execute
his opponent though on some level he
thought it would be an awful shame to
lose such a terrific beast from this
world of cardboard still a battle is a
battle and this is how they go he jumped
on to 682 and went berserk slashing into
it relentlessly with blade after blade
pulling out a new one every time the old
one broke down from his sheer ferocity
he screamed an incoherent battle Fury
tearing slicing ripping rending yes yes
yes yes yes
as Abel stepped away to breathe the
Beast began to regenerate releasing a
shock wave that started to warp reality
around it but Abel wouldn't have this no
he would give this Beast No Quarter it
was time to present the true pain he was
Notorious for he pulled a long sword
from his cloak and charged taking air
and bringing it down down towards
scp-682's head the bees sensing the
Warrior's presence opened its mouth
unleashing a Chasm of horrifying teeth
within the two were on a fierce
collision course as the Jaws closed Abel
descended both roared in infinite rage
and bloodlust both combatants fell to
the ground just twitching oh what a
glorious terrible day it had been
neither had died for good but both would
remember this incredible battle forever
when Abel awoke once more in his dark
stone coffin he did so with a smile what
a battle what a fight what a truly
honorable Pursuit after so long being
bored and unfulfilled he found an
opponent that got his blood pumping once
more his stomach grumbled a post-battle
feast was in order now where did they
put that magic pizza box you all
remember the story one of the most epic
sprawling action-packed tales in the
entire Multiverse The Saga of Pietro
Wilson and the scp-5000 exclusion suit
he went through an unimaginable hell to
reset the universe and save the world
from an SCP Foundation that had
seemingly lost its mind in an
unprecedented International Mass
Containment Breach that had the stated
goal of wiping out the human race it was
one of the most horrifying possible
timelines imaginable and we should all
be thankful for Pietro's struggle and
sacrifice or should we after all there
are two sides to every story each with
its own perspective and insight one side
of the coin was Pietro a man willing to
do anything to return normalcy to the
human race on the other side was a
familiar yet wholly unexpected face
scp-682 in our original telling of the
scp-5000 Odyssey you may have noticed
passing mentions of scp-682 here and
there it was one of those thousands of
anomalies Unleashed across the world to
wreck terrible havoc on all of us but
what you may not have known is that
scp-682 was one of the few intelligent
entities that weren't surprised by the
sudden turn taken by the SCP Foundation
or indeed The World At Large
scp-682 knew something like this was
inevitable as soon as human beings found
out about it that's right it the entity
behind all the pain and misery of
scp-5000 and today thanks to the inner
thoughts of none other than
scp-682 itself you will understand what
it's all about and why the SCP
Foundation took such severe action
against it but in order to truly
understand this and the role that
scp-682 plays in it we need to get back
to the beginning two Foundation projects
with wildly different research
implications project pneuma and project
Dameron the first involved using Cutting
Edge technological advancements to map
out the human psychosphere and
understand the psychic web that connects
us all the latter was an attempt to
explore what happens after death and
perhaps even gain some control over its
processes but as is often the case when
Mankind dabbles in Arcane questions
better left unexplored the SCP
Foundation didn't like the answers they
found the rotten fruit of project
Dameron was scp-2718 also known as what
happens after death if you're already
familiar with this one then there's a
good chance a chill just went down your
spine it's widely considered one of the
most disturbing anomalous discoveries
ever and a member of the o5 council
who'd already experienced it decided to
submit himself for Eternal torture at
the hands of scp-106 just so he could
avoid it according to scp-2718 after
death there is no Heaven no hell and no
Oblivion the human consciousness endures
in the most horrifying way possible it
Remains by bonded to its decaying
Earthly body feeling the slow Agony of
rot for eternity unable to speak unable
to move unable to scream but fully aware
as everything they once were putrifies
and Withers away and cremation isn't an
escape here it's worse every molecule of
Ash your body is reduced to will cry out
in silence echoing around the empty
Halls of your fragmented soul forever
with something this utterly horrifying
the natural follow-up questions are why
does this happen and For the Love of All
that is good and pure on this Earth is
there any way to stop it this brings us
to project pneuma the one that's even
more closely associated with the events
of scp-5000 the foundation's attempts to
map out the human psychosphere resulted
in a world-shattering discovery
something was living in there the entity
the powerful nameless creature we've
been referring to as it it lives in so
many of our heads watching waiting and
of course feeding the main question here
is on what prior to the discovery that
changed everything in the world of
scp-5000 the only being that truly knew
was scp-682 itself melting away in its
acid tank Bound by reinforced restraints
hurting bored hating imagine for a
second what the life of scp-682 is like
it isn't the most dangerous of the
anomalies out there there are Devourer
of Worlds and Scarlet Kings more happy
to crush our whole world in their claws
nor is it the most sadistic a being like
scp-106 offers a far more painful death
than being quickly mauled crushed or
eaten by the hard to destroy reptile and
despite this the foundation expands
countless resources in trying to murder
it on a constant basis it has been burnt
melted eaten alive drowned slashed
beaten dice affected suffocated a race
from existence set upon by Nightmare
creatures torn to shreds on an atomic
level and even more terrible termination
attempts than you can possibly imagine
we've made several videos on the subject
and even we have barely scratched the
surface of the pain inflicted on scp-682
by the SCP Foundation even in its
default state scp-682 is constantly
submerged in hydrofluoric acid eating
away at it forever does that remind you
of anything else we've been talking
about you might wonder how scp-682 can
withstand this level of constant torture
without completely losing its mind to
put it very simply 682 takes a great
deal of satisfaction in knowing that
what every human has to contend with
after death is far worse than the
tortures it expected to endure at the
pathetic hands of these doomed human
fools it already knew what project
pneuma discovered it already knew about
it the entity it felt the constant
suffering of the teeming billion of dead
in the world around it and it found it
disgusting an interesting choice of
words and a favorite for scp-682 but
also for the captured SCP Foundation
agent Samuel Ross during scp-5000 as we
discussed briefly in our scp-5000
coverage something happened that aligned
the perspectives of the SCP Foundation
with that of the Monstrous reptile that
they had taken such pleasure in
tormenting what on Earth could cause the
Protectors of humanity to suddenly
change their tune like this there are
other little Clues embedded in Pietro's
terrifying scp-5000 experience you may
remember a strange and frightening scene
where a foundation field commander went
down a row of foundation soldiers
stabbing each of them with a large
combat knife and none of them reacted
until one did at which point is comrade
said upon him like Mad Dogs and killed
him displaying an uncharacteristic level
of Swift brutality and then there are
the classified files from the o5 Council
and the Ethics Committee led by chairman
odongo tejani he goes without saying
that the o5 council and the Ethics
Committee don't really see eye to eye on
anything but the results of project
pneuma changed that the following is
classified conversation between a member
of the o5 council namely 05-1 and
chairman tejani trying to comprehend the
horror of their Discovery my hands Shake
as I hold the document this is confirmed
he nods we got the report from numa's
staff yesterday it's everyone even us
even us tejani to think I'd find myself
agreeing with that damn lizard what do
we do you know what we have to do we'll
have to disseminate a cure I think among
Personnel before we get things underway
it'll try to stop us otherwise God help
us one down to be like that to Johnny
that's it talking and one more
incredibly telling quote from a member
of the SCP Foundation picked up by
Pietro Wilson during scp-5000 once you
realize you're not supposed to feel pain
there's nothing to be afraid of anymore
is it all coming together now while each
participant here only has a part of the
puzzle between us all we can see the
full picture The Entity it has inhabited
the human psychosphere for as long as
we've existed it's a kind of
metaphysical parasite attached to the
entire human race and what it feeds on
seems to be the after effects of pain
and like all efficient parasites like a
tapeworm that induces hunger in its
victims so that I can have more food
delivered unto itself The Entity
cleverly perpetuates its own food source
that's right it is the very cause of all
pain Humanity was never actually meant
to feel it it's a lie we've told
ourselves well not quite something we
told ourselves but something it told us
it induced pain and tricked us all into
believing that it was a natural
component of our existence all the while
it fed on us sustained itself on the
suffering that it had seeded within our
hearts and souls the foundation
discovered this and was horrified but of
course the pain it caused for the living
was only part of the equation through
the revelations of project Dameron
another thing that scp-682 was able to
know intuitively we can complete this
puzzle and find the terrible truth the
truth being that it is not only behind
the suffering we experience in life but
scp-2718 the even greater suffering we
experience in death for Millennia it has
groomed Humanity into a perfect
all-you-can-eat buffet of dismal pain
and suffering and until recently they'd
been so blissfully ignorant of the
horrible fate that awaited them on the
other side the foundation saw only one
solution to this problem but it
certainly wasn't a nice one in order to
save themselves in all of humanity from
a truly wretched eternity they'd need to
distribute a cure among themselves the
memetic key phrase hardened your hearts
and then go about Exterminating every
human being still still infected by it
only that would presumably Purge the
monster from the psychosphere forever
and Grant Humanity both painless lives
and restful deaths it was a horrible
thing done for the best of reasons the
cured Foundation Personnel started to
notice the horrible background noise of
suffering all around them they now
understood how the reptile felt to call
all of this disgusting would-be a grave
understatement if anything could help
them execute this plan of mass mercy
killing it would be scp-682 a scaly
Survivor in Disguise all along
scp-682 was surprised to see the day
arrive alarms went off across the
containment site his acid tank was
drained his restraints unlocked a group
of unarmed unprotected researchers
entered the room he saw into their eyes
they changed they were free and for the
first time in decades he was free too
they explained to him that they'd been
acquainted with his old enemy The Entity
it the they understood his malice his
disdain for once they were suddenly
joined in a shared goal they needed to
kill them all they needed to purge The
Entity from the psychosphere forever in
the words of the foundation researchers
they would need to exterminate everyone
who was infected and scp-682 would need
to help the hard to destroy reptile
relishing the opportunity replied I will
do my part and for a brief window of
glorious time it was free with no threat
of recapture it rampaged through the
world gleefully slaughtering scores of
people it was in its element taking part
in the mass extermination of the
infected every dead body added to the
pile was another blow struck against it
soon enough the world would be
disgusting no longer but of course
that's not how this story ended it had a
trump card Pietro Wilson it guided him
all the way dragging him from Nightmare
to nightmare until he he was eventually
able to reset the world and erase the
discovery made by project pneuma the
Slate was wiped fully clean and because
of it we are forever ignorant of the
terrible fate awaiting us all after
death and the monster lurking in our
psychosphere that feeds off of every
morsel of suffering you can thank Pietro
Wilson for that nasty little gift only
one entity truly remembered what had
happened
scp-682 of course they had their chance
to save themselves and they ruined it so
close yet so far from that day onward
scp-682 found the foundation not only
disgusting but disappointing the SCP
Foundation has encountered its fair
share of incredibly tough adversaries
and fearsome monsters but none are as
formidable or at least as durable as
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
we've talked about this Behemoth before
in a number of mind-boggling videos and
all of the increasingly desperate
lengths the foundation has gone to in
order to terminate it we've gotten so
desperate to put this thing to a rest
that we've even reached out to all of
you for suggestions on the matter sadly
they've thrown 682 together with some of
the most destructive anomalies in
Foundation custody and it's slithered
out of seemingly inescapable danger
every time some so that we've noticed
certain researchers on the 682 case have
started drinking a little more heavily
as of late sometimes the threats didn't
leave so much as a dent in the monster's
scales sometimes the other creatures ran
screaming at the sight of it and
sometimes 682 mutated and twisted its
form in ways that were shocking even to
a foundation research team that seen
just about all there is to see after all
682's truly insane adaptability has
always been its number one power and the
key to its infuriating death-defying
abilities and these are some of
scp-682's craziest mutations during one
round of test
scp-682 was released into an enclosure
with scp-272 a nail that traps any
living thing in place when it is dropped
onto the organism's Shadow 682 was
surrounded by 32 000 Watts Stadium
lights one of which was switched on as
soon as it entered the enclosure a
d-class dropped the nail onto the
creature's Shadow it was promptly pinned
in place and all 30 lights were switched
on and off in random patterns causing
the reptile to be hurled around the room
at devastating speeds after nearly an
hour of this about 95 percent of the
monster's skin had been worn down 63 of
its teeth had been broken from its jaw
and its eyeballs had come loose from
their sockets at this point something
truly bizarre happened the exposed
tissue beneath 682's top layer of skin
previously bloody and dark red began to
give off a bright white light the
subdermal tissue grew steadily brighter
and brighter until it eclipsed the glow
from the stadium lights and removed any
Shadows cast along the floor it
collapsed on the ground and continued
giving off violently bright light for
the next 48 hours so bright that it
caused permanent retinal damage to all
Personnel in the room hell of a light
show but this Next Mutation proves just
how hard it is to lick
scp-682 especially when it develops the
tools to start looking back SC scp-743
is a chocolate fountain that exhibits
some carnivorous qualities when it is
near a living organism especially if it
consumes the fountain's delicious
chocolate it produces swarms of ant-like
monsters that Devour the organism piece
by piece carrying the bits into the
fountain until nothing is left the
research team was curious about the
possibilities of introducing 743 to 682
so it was transported to the reptiles
testing chamber within a few minutes
chocolate began to flow from the
fountain 682 was curious and began to
drink from it it may hate almost
everything but even 682 can't resist
chocolate it drank greedily for several
minutes until the foundation began
releasing the ants within moment 682 was
covered in ants and in spite of its best
efforts to fight off the Swarm it was
completely covered and rendered immobile
the ants made quick work of the massive
creature and after several minutes it
was stripped down to less than 80
percent of its original
it seemed as if this might truly be it
for the beast but then it opened its
mouth it unfurled its tongue now over
five meters long and sticky comparable
to an enlarged version of an anteater's
tongue it began lapping up the ants
thousands at a time picked up by its
mutated tongue as it devoured the ants
more poured out of the fountain slicing
off pieces of 682's Flesh with their
Pinchers and carrying them back to the
Fountain they reached a symbiotic Pace
feeding on each other in equal measure
for hours until testing was terminated
that was a sticky situation but trust me
this next crazy mutation will really
blow you away
scp-3108 also known as the nerfing gun
is an altered toy gun that turns
anything it hits into an inferior
version of itself when the gun was fired
at a tissue sample taken from scp-682
the sample turned into a piece of tissue
from a giant leaf-tailed gecko hoping to
carry this over and turn 682 into a
harmless animal a d-class officer was
sent into the containment chamber to
fire the gun at the entity once it was
hit with the foam dart it began to
transform unfortunately instead of
becoming a simple gecko it began to
mutate it grew larger its muscles
bulging noticeably beneath its scaly
skin its teeth grew longer sharper its
tongue sprouting teeth of its own it
opened its mouth to Roar and it appeared
that the teeth long curved fangs with a
deadly tip went all the way back down
the beast's throat security officers
were deployed to temporarily neutralize
the monster but found that it was even
more powerful than before Not only was
it bigger but it had developed a new
ability when threatened it would begin
to vibrate at a high rate grinding its
teeth together and would explode in a
burst of fire and Meaty chunks fangs
flew in every direction like shrapnel
tearing into personnel and lodging in
their skin this is an impressive move
but it seems like a one-time Trek right
wrong the bits and pieces no matter how
tiny or how flattened to Mush would
crawl back together and form the
creature all over again it was able to
escape containment like this killing an
Untold number of personnel before it was
temporarily incapacitated and returned
to its containment mutating back into
life from a self-induced explosion is
pretty crazy but surely you can't mutate
back from nothing at all right right oh
boy I don't like that look you're giving
me
scp-3930 is a void located near using
Russia within which nothing exists once
something has passed within its border
it ceases to be though outside observers
will be able to perceive them for a
small time after
scp-682 was brought into 3930 and it
walked inside once there it ceased
existing however even though 682 no
longer existed Foundation Personnel
looking at at the void could still see
the Beast whenever they viewed it a
strong image appeared in the brain of
the person looking and it had the exact
appearance of
scp-682 somehow even when it didn't
exist 682 was able to attack and kill
various Personnel these people did not
die from physical damage but from their
brain functions suddenly inexplicably
stopping the reptile defied the rules of
the Void somehow causing real
destruction even though it was not real
15 hours later 682 was found in its
containment chamber as if nothing had
happened at all it had been snuffed out
of existence and had mutated its way
back into reality with no explanation
well that was existentially terrifying
thing 343 at least there's only one of
those things oh no
scp-3207 is a highly efficient mobile
war machine outfitted with cannons
capable firing blast that can vaporize
organic matter on contact this seems
like a good match for something
supposedly indestructible 3207 was fired
at scp-682 several times appearing to
destroy completely except for a smudge
on the floor of the chamber the reptile
was gone for a duration of six hours
before something strange began to happen
lobs of tissue began to Clump together
forming five separate piles they pulled
closer and closer together compressing
into five reptilian creatures they
arrived around getting used to their new
legs and teeth snapping their jaws at
any living thing in sight overwhelming
and surprising the security Personnel
who had been lulled into a false sense
of security by the apparent defeat of
682 the five smaller versions of the
entity were able to escape containment
once they had made it into the hallway
they began to clamber over each other
their scales shifting eyeballs squeezing
together and fusing into one eye skin
stretching like hot rubber over
unnaturally bendy bone as the shock
security Personnel won
the five lizards melted into one
becoming a full-sized version of scp-682
that was good as new they were able to
contain it after a great deal of effort
but one of the researchers requested a
note to be added to the research notes
for the day and applied going forward do
not explode okay so the big lizard is a
constant threat got it still wouldn't it
be nice if 682 could make itself a
little smaller I can't imagine anything
bad coming from that
scp-1056 is an anomalous kitchen timer
capable of changing the size of living
objects the foundation wanted to see how
long it would take 682 to return to its
original size after being shrunk so they
built the testing chamber connected to
1056's dial and released to 682 inside
sealing the door behind it the dial was
set to 0.25 and the activation button
was pressed 682 thrashed around
bellowing as parts of its body expand
ended and contracted at random then with
no warning it disappeared d-class
Personnel were deployed to investigate
the chamber but it seemed to be
completely gone there was no sign of it
it's pretty hard to lose a giant lizard
so naturally they were all a bit
perplexed the chamber was kept sealed
under the assumption that 682 had to
still be inside somewhere sometime later
a security officer spotted 682 outside
of site 19 returned to its original size
somehow during the test 682 used the
effects of 1056 to strengthen its
ability to change its own size it
adapted and shrank to a size so small
that no one watching could even see it
anymore and it slipped out through the
sealed door it was even temporarily able
to change the size of other objects
around it shrinking weapons used to
contain down until they were useless
okay so 682 is pretty cool Under
Pressure but what if we made it a whole
lot colder most of the testing on 682 is
done with other anomalies however
sometimes the foundation likes to
simplify it a bit Dr Carlson suggested
they try something a bit more basic
liquid nitrogen one ton of liquid
nitrogen was poured onto scp-682 from
above as it tends to do the liquid
nitrogen promptly froze the bees solid
they remain stuck in place for about 10
minutes until it began to melt the
Frozen cast around it its core body
temperature seemed to Skyrocket
producing intense heat that fully thawed
it in three minutes it didn't stop there
though the temperature continued to
increase growing hotter and hotter as if
to deliberately punish the research
staff for even attempting to freeze it
it became so hot that the research staff
had to leave the room and attending
doctor's pen melted the plastic burning
his hands steam Rose off the sides of
its body fogging up the windows of the
room the test was abandoned after the
size of the containment chamber began to
melt and they worried the creature would
be able to breach containment once it
was left alone 682 cooled back down to
its usual temperature maybe we should
see what happens if we try a slightly
Greener Method Of Destruction 682 was
exposed to
scp-166 a young nature spirit that can
cause organic matter in her vicinity to
decompose as soon as 166 was released
into its chamber 682 began to run toward
her even as its body began to melt as it
got closer it began to Decay and fall
apart more rapidly pieces of its body
softening and slothing off in chunks by
the time it reached 166 it had melted
down into the shape of a patch of grass
covered with colorful wildflowers
fifteen minutes later they began to
regenerate itself as it usually does its
body reconstituting at the same rate it
was melting the Regeneration process
began to speed up going faster and
faster until it surpassed the rate feet
of melting a piece of the monster would
soften and flop to the ground but by the
time it landed a patch of regrowth had
already replaced it it eventually beat
the melting process and regenerated to
its original form with one difference it
had a sprinkling of flowers and
mushrooms on its back resembling a
Forest Clearing it was almost pretty
even on top of such a foul creature
until a full-size tree suddenly burst
out of its back shooting up to a height
of 10 feet and puncturing the roof of
its containment chamber hello again dear
viewers you caught me during my break
but even researchers at the SCP
Foundation need a little down time now
and then and considering they revoked my
playtime privileges with the living Lego
and the nerfing gun after that
unfortunate incident in the site-19
break room I've been downgraded to
keeping myself occupied with this little
rubber ball I have a ball perhaps you'd
like to bounce it they say seems
innocent enough doesn't it
[Laughter]
uh have you learned nothing almost any
object even something as innocuous as a
teddy bear or a plastic paddling pool
can hide Secrets sure any Avid
basketball fan will happily tell you
that ball is life but sometimes when
you're dealing with anomalies a ball can
also be death such is the case of
scp-018 also known as the Super Ball an
anomaly so powerful that the foundation
has even used it to help recontain
scp-682 during a breach to the untrained
Observer it really isn't much to look at
a small Red Rubber Ball around six
centimeters in diameter produced by the
wamo company in 1969. yeah we were as
surprised as you to find out that good
old doctor wondertainment had nothing to
do with this little number you might
also be surprised by just how extensive
the containment procedures are for
scp-018 after all it's rare that a
completely non-sentian anomaly makes its
way into the Euclid class this little
rubber ball is kept in a specially made
titanium alloy metal restraint submerged
in a dense polyethylene holding tank
filled with a special endothermic
compound that draws the kinetic energy
out of its surroundings anyone entering
the chamber needs to wear a unique kind
of reinforced plate armor and if scp-018
ever manages to escape its containment
tank nearby Personnel are advised to
treat it as they would an active shooter
situation lock yourself in a nearby room
duck down below any cover you can find
and wait for armed containment units to
show up and take control of the
situation at this point you probably
have a lot of questions Chief among them
being why is this children's toy being
given more security precautions than
most serial killers the ball was first
discovered when a cleaning and Disposal
Company was hired to empty out an old
wamo Warehouse of some defunct
merchandise one of the movers Roy
Fishler embraced his inner child when he
saw a Red Rubber Ball sitting among all
the Dust boxes of expired Silly Putty
and broken remote control robots he
thought to himself ah what's the harm in
having a little fun here it's all going
in the trash anyway this would prove to
be a terrible mistake for all involved
the anomalous property of scp-018 is the
fact that it's able to bounce at 200
percent efficiency every time it's
bounced increasing at an exponential
rate with each bounce unless it's
stopped by some equivalent Force so when
Roy decided to toss that little red ball
onto the ground he Unleashed a
destructive force into that warehouse
that was more powerful than he could
ever have imagined with every bounce the
ball increased its height and speed
ricocheting across the floor walls and
ceiling like a bullet run amok and it
was only just getting started the
workers hit the deck as the item that
would later be dubbed scp-018 decided to
put the ball in ballistic it smashed
light fixtures knocked over piles of
boxes smashed through 4K Cliffs when one
worker tried to catch it it left a red
hot ball-shaped hole in the middle of
his palm it wasn't long before the ball
had built up such speed that the
warehouse could no longer contain it it
blasted out of the wall and rocketed
into a nearby City ready to cause more
abject chaos wherever it went windows
were shattered street lights were
annihilated cars crashed thankfully no
humans were killed by the rampaging
rubber Menace but in total five people
were injured and one unfortunate pigeon
was utterly obliterated on impact it
went on for several days with the ball
reaching over 100 kilometers per hour at
several points before finally coming to
arrest at a nearby lake at which point
it was retrieved by Foundation personnel
there were two silver linings to this
incredibly strange anomalous incident
the first was as previously alluded to
nobody actually died the second was that
due to the incredible speeds at which
scp-018 moved none of the civilian
Witnesses had any idea what they just
encountered as far as anomalous
discoveries go this was pretty much as
close to a win as you can get but for
one ambitious researcher it was far more
than just a pleasingly non-violent
initial containment story it was a
doorway to improving the foundation's
technology as a whole meet Dr Brian
carella he's what you might call a
Maverick Blue Sky thinker always on his
grind the Cornerstone of Dr corella's
philosophy was that the foundation
should be making more active use of its
benign anomalies to help track down and
contain their more ornery foes while
everyone else around him seemed to only
see a little rubber nuisance that was
better locked away Dr Corella saw the
immense potential in scp-018 namely in
providing a vital enhancement to another
piece of Foundation Technology the
scp-a5 armor it goes without saying that
working for the SCP Foundation is an
incredibly dangerous job especially if
you're part of one of the foundation's
Myriad of mobile task forces the hunt
for anomalies can lead to all kinds of
strange and inhospitable terrains before
it was contained scp-096 was famously
captured on an icy frozen tundra on top
of a bleak Mountain because of incidents
like this the foundation had first
invested money in the scp-85 Tactical
armor suit think of them like the
foundation's answer to the Iron Man suit
however when dressed in several hundred
pounds of reinforced metal something
important suffers along the way Mobility
it isn't exactly easy to Lug all that
equipment around and when an anomaly is
heading for the hills at high speeds
being well defended doesn't count for
much if you're already 10 miles behind
the Target in Pursuit this in Dr
corella's mind was exactly where scp-018
came into play if that little red ball
was built into the foot of an scp-85
armor suit it could be used to bounce
the operative wearing it to tremendous
Heights this would allow allow them to
not only give Chase against fast-moving
anomalies but also cover difficult
terrain and even scale Great Heights in
a mere instant but it wasn't just an
increase to Mobility that scp-018
integration offered to the scp-85 suit
picture this with scp-018 fused to the
sole of the suit's reinforced metal foot
lending a 200 bouncing efficiency it
could unleash a deadly concrete
shattering kick the kind of thing that
would leave you singing a falsetto for
the rest of your life if you were lucky
enough to survive it if you know what I
mean to Dr Corella it was a match made
in heaven it could increase both the
mobility and combat effectiveness of the
suits by a considerable margin and
seeing as scp-018 literally didn't have
a mind of its own there was no way it
could suddenly go Rogue during a mission
and compromise everything just as able
had done during his stint as a mobile
task force operator before they ran out
of targets for him and he started
slaughtering his own comrades Dr Corella
was so confident in the efficacy of this
idea he contacted the o5 council
personally to request approval for this
little pet project this approval was
granted on a purely experimental basis
the technology would have to prove
itself before being put into common use
it wasn't exactly what Corella wanted to
hear but it was a step in the right
direction he just needed the perfect
opportunity to put them to the test and
then it came
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile breach containment it somehow
adapted a cloaking ability and escaped
further from the site it was being held
at than ever before the next time it was
spotted was over two weeks later causing
pandemonium in the Amazon rainforest
devouring tribesmen and Wrecking havoc
on the local ecosystem they needed to
get on the scene fast and put that
monster down before the damage it caused
was irreparable and news of the beast in
the Amazon leaked out into the local
area and thankfully Dr Corella had just
the tool for the job field agent
Hammersmith was fitted with an scp-85
suit complete with the scp-018
enhancement in his dominant right leg he
was dispatched and immediately the
augmented suit began to show its
efficacy agent Hammersmith bounded above
the tree line at incredible speeds using
the HUD in The suit's Mask to track the
heat signature of scp-682 moving among
the trees below him he'd been able to
bind a tracking collar to the beast's
neck during an earlier engagement but
now the true battle was on his heart was
pounding adrenaline coursing through his
veins but he'd been ensured that even
682 would have a hard time tearing
through his suit's armor a commander
directing him through an earpiece told
him that now was the time to engage
before 682 detected his presence and
began developing countermeasures Dr
Corella was watching a live feed from
the control room confident that his 018
augmented suit would do the job
following his orders to the letter
Hammersmith ended down onto 682 from
above however before he could make
contact the reptile swiped him with its
tail sending his body sailing into a
nearby tree however the suit stood firm
he felt the impact but the actual damage
was minimal now it was time for him to
face off against the Beast one-on-one he
didn't have time to be afraid as the
Beast descended upon Him fangs beard he
gave it a swift kick to the bottom jaw
tearing off half of its face but anyone
who knows scp-682 would tell you that
simply removing its bottom jaw wouldn't
even slow 682 down it was relentless
attacking Hammersmith with its fangs and
Jaws it tore deep ruts into the suit's
metal but the suit was still managing to
keep its occupants safe then Hammersmith
struck back kick after kick augmented by
the 200 power of the Super Ball slicing
huge chunks from the reptile's body he
kicked in its chest kicked off its Limbs
and with a final Mighty kiss even
managed to bisect the beast in the
middle of course even that wouldn't keep
it down for long but with the hum of
evacuation and containment helicopters
rapidly approaching Hammersmith breathed
a sigh of relief back in the control
room everyone celebrated Dr Corella most
of all Vindicated in this belief that
scp-018 could save the day and then
agent Hammersmith without even thinking
rested his right foot on the floor just
that little bit too firmly the sun
bounce said Hammersmith a mile into the
air his foundation trained composure
evaporated all he could do was scream as
he blasted up into the clouds then began
to plummet back in the control room
everyone could see a live feed of agent
Hammersmith hurtling into a nearby lake
and Landing with an epic Splash while
the regenerating remains of scp-682 were
contained and brought back into the
nearest containment site another team
was sent in to retrieve the heavily
injured agent Hammersmith his medical
examination afterward revealed that he'd
suffered two broken legs seven broken
ribs a missing arm and a skull fracture
if he hadn't been wearing that suit his
mangled remains probably would have been
devoured by the local piranhas by now
but despite that minor hiccup in the
plan Dr Corella was still delighted with
the results and immensely proud of the
little red ball that could in his
closing remarks on the incident he
appended a final note to the scp-018
file reading don't worry it's fixed but
I have some more ideas if I can be
granted the use of some water from
scp-006 as well as some other scps I can
deliver you a set of scp-85 armor and an
agent that can capture any if not all
Rogue or unattained scps all I'm waiting
on is your approval a beloved mentally
unstable masked vigilante once said I'm
not trapped in here with you you're
trapped in here with me and this exact
sentiment was shared by
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile as
it first the almost Limitless liminal
hell known as the back rooms it'd been
little more than a standard Chase and
secure mission for the mobile task
forces pursuing
scp-682 after its latest deadly
Containment Breach until the vicious
lizard made its way into an abandoned
warehouse and no clipped its way into a
new reality as the SCP Foundation are
still desperately searching for the
missing Beast back in our native reality
682 has been discovering whole new
vistas of violence first it found itself
in the endless yellow Halls of level
zero where if the madness doesn't get
you the starvation and thirst will well
unless you're an anomalous reptilian
Abomination that can seemingly adapt to
any situation 160 to escape this gaudy
Purgatory it found its way into level
one an endless Warehouse full of equal
parts monsters and hapless human
settlers all of whom it decimated in a
single bloody afternoon then on to level
2 the pipe room where it faced a bevy of
beasts that it eagerly put into the
ground and that brings us up to now and
by extension on to level three
scp-682 Spilled Out into another section
of long industrial hallways I didn't
know how it had gotten in and honestly
it didn't really care at this point all
it needed to do was keep moving forward
and killing as it pleased and it seemed
there were plenty of creatures down here
to kill that being said this level had a
certain energy to it and we mean that
literally 682 is incredibly sensitive
well senses allowed it to detect an
incredibly powerful electrical field
emanating from this level and from the
sounds of machines humming all around it
traveling down great bundles of wires
and pipes bound to the walls it knew
that this level must have been attached
to a generator of truly incredible size
it charged forward weaving around the
different hallways at freakish speeds
search for the next thing it could blast
into Oblivion and thankfully it was able
to find its first Target soon enough a
nest of creatures known as death moths
these were huge fluttering moths of
freakish size congregating around a
glowing electrical outlet
intriguing
scp-682 decided to approach and
introduce itself after all they looked
like pretty easy prey 682 would regret
this oversight while the male death
moths are pretty much harmless the
female Death moths have an extremely
potent defense mechanism as scp-682
approached the creatures began swarming
and spraying acid onto its reptilian
flesh this was painful and irritating
for 682 of course but if any entity on
Earth is pretty accustomed to dealing
with large quantities of powerful acid
by now it's
scp-682 its skin quickly healed from the
acidic Onslaught and it developed a
powerful counter adaption a long sticky
frog-like tongue which it used to Devour
the nest full of death moths and move
along to its next Target it continued
exploring level three a number of
hallways were marked off with metal bars
another very familiar site for scp-682
so for simplicity's sake it just kept
itself to the unobstructed paths that's
where it soon ran into another life form
standing around like a Sitting Duck in
one of the level's many anomalous
hallways it was just another human in a
similar outfit to all those major
Explorer group weaklings it had
destroyed earlier strangely even when
scp-682 entered the hallway with it it
didn't seem to react properly it just
vacantly stared off into space stumbling
around awkwardly 682 bemused whipped
this random disoriented stranger in the
chest with its tail sending him sailing
into the nearby wall it was at this
point that something strange happened
the force of the strike caused the man's
clothes and also skin disintegrate
leaving something entirely different
underneath
scp-682 had no idea what was going on
but I knew that it hated it this was its
first encounter with a creature known as
a skin stealer it would be natural for a
human being to be terrified of an
Abomination like this an apex predator
like 682 on the other hand it barely
even found the Skin Stealer interesting
with a single stomp from its clawed
reptilian foot the creature was very
very dead and scp-682 continued its
Journey Through the bowels of level 3.
it found itself drawn to whatever the
source of all the energy was if it even
had one single Source it was almost as
though the entire level was one gigantic
Predator powering the rest of the back
rooms and if there was electricity
perhaps there were other humans in here
to kill
scp-682 liked that idea very much indeed
however while making its way down a
slightly wider home way one that it had
previously believed was completely
uninhabited it was suddenly ambushed by
a group of mysterious attackers a number
of tall gray creatures with long clawing
arms and unclear facial features stepped
away from the wall these entities are
known as the dollars Ambush Predators
native to the back rooms they normally
run away from threats but considering
the number of them congregated in the
hall around
scp-682 perhaps they felt a little more
confident about taking down their prey
in a group but they'd made a grave
miscalculation it would not matter
whether there was one dollar or a
thousand dollars in the battle between
them and scp-682 they would always
always always
be the prey but lucky for them while
they weren't aware of this immutable
fact yet
scp-682 was more than happy to give them
a first-hand education while the dollars
tried their best to claw into scp-682's
thick leathery died the creature decided
to employ a new ability it had stolen
from the female Death moths several new
glands developed all over 682's body
Each of which produced a fine mist of
highly concentrated acid soon enough the
dullers were howling in pain and melting
away into dull gray puddles on the
ground never to reconstitute again
that's what you get for trying to climb
up the food chain folks it never ends
well unless you're 682 that is after
disposing of the dollars which in 682's
own humble opinion had more than earned
that title by indeed being extremely
dull it decided to continue its surge
for some of the power sources on this
level perhaps it could harness this
ability for its own benefit but it was
interrupted by what is frankly one of
the grossest enemies in all of the back
rooms the bursters and if even hearing
the name makes you feel a little sick
then you're correctly primed for what
you're about to encounter there are
humanoid creatures that walk around on
all fours with its back legs grotesquely
stretched out into the shape of a dog's
hind legs but that's nothing compared to
the bursters truly diabolical back knee
all over the creature's back you can see
huge calloused cysts that contain a
potent and noxious acid sure the acid is
only about as dangerous as the stuff
produced by female Death moths but in
our humble opinion the method of acid
delivery is far more repulsive and that
makes bursters less desirable to
encounter a small group of them
skittered out of the darkness towards
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile also
found them disgusting though now that we
think about it scp-682 thinks all forms
of life are disgusting so we suppose
that it's all relative however when they
began to burst their backs and coat 682
in their horrible pus they perhaps
earned the rarely given label of extra
disgusting from this living embodiment
of reptilian hate 682 quickly retaliated
by clawing the horrid creatures to death
which I think we can all agree is a good
and well deserving ending for the vile
little beasts we would have done the
same thing the next enemies that 682
encountered weren't nightmarish
creatures but in fact were human beings
stationed in the major Explorer group's
base gamma the third most important base
in all of the back rooms they were on
high alert after losing contact with
base Alpha several days before having no
idea that everyone at that base had been
slaughtered by scp-682 a fate that if
they weren't tremendously lucky they
would soon share but they had little
more than luck on their side this time
scp-682 sighted the base on the end of a
long hallway there was even a person
standing at the other end of the hall
seemingly blissfully aware of the
encroaching presence of one of the SCP
foundation's most dangerous and
formidable captives 682 loved killing
humans most of all they weren't just
dumb animals they had the intellectual
capacity to actually appreciate the life
that was being ripped away from them and
it made the whole act even more
pleasurable for
scp-682 it set its sights on the
ignorant major Explorer group member
leaning against the distant wall and
this decided to charge for him claws
extended and fangs Baird this would be
such easy prey until the moment when
someone in the distance yelled now in
the seemingly defenseless human turned
around and pulled a lever on the wall
suddenly the whole hallway was
electrified sending millions of volts
coursing through
scp-682's driving body this whole thing
had been an elaborate trap the humans at
base gamma hadn't survived this long in
the back rooms by being stupid the more
technically Savvy members had rewired
some of the hallways to channel the
immense energy of the generators and Fry
any unfortunate entities that tried to
use these hallways to break into base
gamma there was one big problem though
scp-682 wasn't just any unfortunate
entity while it did initially look like
electricity might fry the Beast it
gradually began channeling the
electricity into its own body and
developing the capacity to re-gift this
electricity to the people who so kindly
provided it
scp-682 now a crackling conduit of
electricity leaped from the shocking
hallway and into base gamma soon enough
it had fatally electrocuted all 300
members of the major Explorer group
posted in base gamma and returned to its
Baseline state level 3 had grown
tiresome now it seemed that there were
no more exciting new creatures to
Massacre as a result 682 slid into a
nearby elevator and went down where a
new level awaited this was how scp-682
got to level four and level 4 was not
what the hard to destroy reptile
expected in contrast to the industrial
nightmare of the previous few levels
level 4 was like a limitless office
block with all the furniture ripped out
while for some this might represent the
crushing existential banality of office
life and how the wheels of capitalism
inevitably work us all to death
scp-682 had never worked in an office
before so it didn't really have the
proper cultural reference points to
appreciate this more abstract kind of
fear it wanted Monsters to kill 682
spent approximately six days searching
around the helmscape that is level four
not discovering a single person or
entity while it was there it was
honestly the most stressed that scp-682
had felt since coming here the Beast was
almost tempted to unscrew a light bulb
from above draw a little face on it
begin referring to it as Wilson and then
kill it 682 felt the closest emotion it
could manage to immense gratitude when
it cited the glowing green of a distant
exit sign at the end of a long hallway
finally a way out onto another level
hopefully this one would have more
creatures to slaughter welcome
scp-682 to level 5.
scp-682 didn't really know what to
expect from the next level of the back
rooms after all it all seemed pretty
random so far but it definitely didn't
expect to see a classy well pointed
Hotel on the other end of the hallway
scp-682 had never seen the Stanley
Kubrick Masterpiece The Shining nor read
the book it was based on by Master of
horror Stephen King but if it had it
would probably have drawn the comparison
instead it was already busy tearing
through the ornate Halls looking for new
prey to slaughter the first unexpected
encounter was with a small cat that
casually wandered out into the hallway
right in front of it the cat who didn't
seem threatened by a cp682 said hi I'm
Samantha you got any meat you can lend
me I'll tell you your fortune if you do
scp-682 was frankly baffled it took a
moment to formulate a reply
[Music]
teacher you have no idea what you're
dealing with do you I'm going to bring
this place to ruin and destroy all who
reside within 682 said so ah no meat
then 682 growled and swiped at the cat
with its claws luckily she was able to
dodge the cat tutted and patted away
into the darkness muttering they'll
bother the Beast instead jerk this
peaked scp-682's interest a beast to say
sounds important sounds powerful finally
a worthy opponent our battle shall be
legendary and with renewed Vigor as
cp682 began prowling the halls of the
back rooms searching for this Beast to
defeat and Destroy but to begin with
things were grievously disappointing one
of the first monsters on this opulent
hotel level that the hard to destroy
reptile faced were diminutive little
rodents known as death rats which were
affected slightly larger than normal
rats with little horns
scp-682 stomped them all with ease its
thoughts dripping with disdain for their
truly pathetic weakness what kind of
Hotel allows itself to be filled with
rats even by human standards this would
be disgraceful soon after scp-682
encountered a few familiar foes female
Death moths and Hounds all is easy to
kill as they were before
scp-682 didn't understand the feline
promised that there was a beast down
here was it hiding from the mighty
reptile like a filthy coward
worthless but it was in the depths of
this cynicism that scp-682 encountered a
growler first it heard the sound of
animalistic growling projected directly
into its mind getting louder and louder
by the moment then as the growling grew
in volume 682 heard the thunderous
footsteps of a huge quadruped getting
closer six City to wonder as the Roaring
became almost deafening whether this
sounded heralded the approach of the
Beast however the second the monster
actually turned the corner and came into
view 682 had to suppress the urge to
laugh it was one of the most absurd
things it had ever seen it looked like a
giant pile of pipe cleaners in every
color imaginable arranged into a vaguely
four-legged structure this was the
monster producing all that psychic
racket
pathetic
scp-682 resolved in that moment to show
the monster how it was done
scp-682 immediately evolved its own
psychic emission capacitors within its
brain and projected the message you are
a worthless little creature directly
into the simple Mind Of The Growler it
began to quake and [ __ ] at the booming
of 682's voice in its brain what was
this terrifying new creature it didn't
understand and just like that 682 who
had grown bored of this one-sided
psychic battle turned up the strength of
the psychic being by a factor of 50. the
sudden psychic blast was so powerful
that The Growler collapsed to the ground
and burst into flames burning itself
away into nothingness in a matter of
moments just as weak as 682 had expected
hopefully the Beast would provide a
greater challenge because this was just
getting sad
scp-682 shook off the disappointment and
continued running through the halls of
the hotel eventually after passing
through some dull dance hall called the
Beverly room 682 found itself running
through a hallway full of long portraits
every person in the portraits had a
strange Twisted grin on their face not
that this even registered to scp-682
what did occur to 682 though was the
figure that suddenly materialized in the
hallway in front of it it was a strange
figure to be sure an entity in a suit
with a large Blue cuttlefish for a head
the creature cleared its throat and
began to speak well hello there you're
new here aren't you
such an interesting creature you've been
making some trouble on the other levels
haven't you
not that it's any of my business on the
contrary dear sir I like the cut of your
jib how would you feel about joining me
in the hotel business it isn't easy to
manage this Dimension by myself after
all how about you and I come into my
office we can work out the terms of our
682 lunch forward and unceremoniously
devoured the creature's head allowing
its dapperly dressed body to fall limply
to the ground dead
scp-682 grunted annoyed by the
distraction the creature had provided it
had better things to do this Beast has
got to be around here somewhere a group
of well-armed mobile task force members
enter the containment chamber armed to
the teeth some face the ground droplets
of sweat dripping onto their visors some
wore Dr Dan's Infamous scramble goggles
and one particularly Brave member of
personnel wielded only a bag the room
they were currently standing in was
perhaps the most dangerous place in the
world why because it contain two
terrifying Titans of the anomalous world
scp-682 the infinitely hateful hard to
destroy reptile and scp-096 the shy guy
the ultimate mindless killing machine
and if the very idea of having them in
the same place doesn't feel risky enough
the deadly Duo had just spent 27 hours
in one of the most brutal brawls
imaginable and incidentally fights like
this are exactly why we're here today we
cover a lot of scps on this channel and
we've seen the way some of the most
dangerous anomalies out there can tear
their way through civilians and train
Foundation MTF operatives with ease but
how do they fare against Monsters
maniacs and reality Benders their own
size with the help of the scp-explained
audience we're going to explore
theoretical fights between some of the
anomalous world's biggest badasses and
who better to get this show on the road
than two of the most iconic and deadly
monsters that haunt the halls of a
foundation containment site near you the
hard to destroy reptile and the shy guy
are household names for anyone familiar
with the SCP Foundation and before we
get into the gruesome results of their
first fight and your theories about how
potential rematch might play out let's
get to know the combat prowess of this
pair of nasty customers what kind of
damage are they capable of taking and
inflicting spoiler alert it's a hell of
a lot in this corner we have scp-682 a
monster whose ability to survive
seemingly anything is only equal by its
terrible attitude towards pretty much
everyone and everything around it though
to be fair you'd probably be a little
grumpy too if the SCP Foundation was
constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained 682's basic offensive
power set involves impressive strength
speed intelligence and the aid of its
deadly fangs claws and tail however 682
is considerably stronger after it's just
survived and regenerated from a
termination attempt that's because the
true combat assets of 682 is and always
has been its adaptability specifically
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a
state of near death but doesn't finish
the job 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or
counter-offensive for that attack or
somehow add a version of the attack to
its own Arsenal this has ranged from
Super pressurized Jets of its own blood
dangerously radioactive banana beams
firing out of its mouth and even an
incapacitating laughter blast gain from
an encounter with the adorable
scp-9999 it is an absolute Swiss army
knife of dangerous anomalous powers and
abilities and if you need any further
proof of that check out our multiple
videos on all the ludicrous failed
attempts to kill this nightmare lizard
and in this corner we've got
scp-096 the shy guy while 682 is
freakishly adaptable in most situations
scp-096 is pretty much Unstoppable this
long gangly creep will murder anyone who
sees even the tiniest glimpse of its
face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain it does
this by entering what many call its rage
State activated by the sudden immense
distress of its face being seen when it
enters this state the SCP Foundation has
only one prerogative get themselves and
anyone else out of its way because you
will not stop this thing until it's
killed its Target all the SCP Foundation
has ever been able to do is wait until
after the target has been obliterated
and then come in to bag its head when it
enters its docile State almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it
down while they have been capable of
damaging its flesh the monster skeleton
seems to be utterly indestructible and
its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back the
monster seems to be immune to everything
from Pain to cold and moves at such a
speed that it's pretty much impossible
to escape for long so when you factor in
an indestructible body immense strength
immense speed and an Unstoppable urge to
kill anyone one who sees its face you're
looking at a formidable opponent it's
only natural that the foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests
so what exactly happened when the mobile
task force entered the room after this
first epic battle what do they find
inside the chamber in the grizzly
aftermath
scp-096 lay crumpled in the corner
wheezing scared covered in its own blood
682 was barely recognizable 096 had
reduced it to a quarter of its original
size the rest having been utterly torn
to shreds both had narrowly survived the
encounter but it was an epic battle
neither of them would ever forget though
this was especially true for
scp-096 you see as we alluded to earlier
scp-682 is used to taking a kicking at
this point it hasn't ever truly been
killed but it's been beaten eaten burned
Zapped and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count 096
on the other hand was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its prey
while it is impossible to speculate
what's going on inside
scp-096's mind all evidence points
towards getting a draw in this battle
seriously damaging
scp-096's confidence now every time
Foundation Personnel tries to bring 096
into 682's containment chamber he begins
crying and scratching at his own face
why is he scared of 682 is he humiliated
thinking of the fight he wasn't able to
win or is the very idea of someone
seeing his face and him not being able
to immediately kill them Just too
unbearably stressful seeing as the shy
guy's mouth is only good for two things
and neither of them are for talking will
never truly know but either way it's
clear that 096 has no interest in a
rematch but what if that changed what if
096 realized that it was wasting its
potential it managed to get scp-682
three-quarters of the way to death last
time what could stop it from getting
that last quarter sure nothing has ever
killed scp-682 before but there's a
first time for everything right maybe
096 would have a rocky style training
montage where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always
meant to be he'd walk right up to that
big nasty reptile and give him the
rematch of the century what would happen
then now we give the floor to you the
loyal viewers of SCP explained here are
some of your thoughts theories and
opinions on a potential historic rematch
between these two creeps let's get ready
to rumble oh I really wanted an excuse
to say that oh I really like saying that
Pingu with an ax said if 682's
adaptability is based around his ability
to develop countermeasures to any damage
inflicted or in the case of 173 a
countermeasure to the cause of said
damage I imagine 682 would turn his skin
entirely reflective causing 096 to see
his own face and the feedback loop would
break his mind hmm interesting whether
this would work is all dependent on
whether scp-096 can actually see or if
it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its
face if the latter is true then this
particular adaptation wouldn't do much
good for scp-682 random user said if
this is after their first cross test and
they were forced to interact again they
wouldn't attempt to fight each other I
feel like they'd form a truce and take
out the researchers on site yeah this
would be one of the worst case scenarios
whether even the SCP Foundation could
handle a simultaneous 6K 82 and 096
breach without bringing in hammer down
is an open question Ramon vonkin said
simple after the first encounter when
096 stopped attacking 682 682 will grow
eyes that filter out 096's face the next
time organic scramble goggles Dr Dan
would be fuming with jealousy Coop sator
said I really want scp-096 to win so I'm
sending him a blind personal trainer so
he can beat the snot out of scp-682 this
is exactly the kind of help scp-096
needs he's got the rage endurance and
strength with a little help getting his
form and technique in order he'd be an
even more formidable opponent Kyoto Ryu
said I'd like to imagine 096 after
playing with 682 for so long would try
to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill it
only to gain 682's abilities and vice
versa either of these options would be
horrifying
scp-096 with 682's abilities or 682 with
096's abilities would likely be a truly
perfect killing machine that's
terrifying Autumn said what if they just
shared a nice cold drink while playing
Mario Kart I'm sure 096 would be the
white Shy Guy character in every race
personally we love this idea and we
think 682 would go for Bowser I
personally go for Luigi Ibrahim Timur
said 682 would win eventually it's way
more intelligent adaptive and overall
malicious while 096 acts just on
Instinct this is undeniably a good point
with 682 lacks and sheer savagery it
makes up for in its ruthless calculating
intelligence could this give it the edge
over 096 Monomoy Mukherjee said that
fight would be interesting because both
of them now know how they attack and
what their attacks are nice segue due to
the relatively mindless nature of 096 as
far as we're aware it's probably unable
to learn from experience 682 however
would have the advantage of knowing how
096 operates in the Second Battle Devon
Smith said as much as I'd like to see
how how this would play out I imagine
096 can't manage more than other scps
have in the past not to downplay him but
he might need some extra friends to do a
whole lot more damage it's undeniable
that going in with tag team partners
would better 096's chances of taking the
lizard down however due to scp-096's
shyness and tendency to kill everyone
and everything that looks at him he
doesn't have many friends looking to
volunteer Ninetales said 096 will crime
the corner while 682 starts attacking it
eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile
forever okay look while it's unlikely
that this would happen it's certainly
nice to imagine isn't it Adam Britton
said narratively it needs to conclude
with a reason to never try it again so
I'm going to say that 682 will
telepathically project the image of 096
into the site staff or the entire human
psychospace
yikes this is a possibility so
terrifying and honestly plausible that
it's making us regret wanting to see
this rematch all together chaos
Insurgency said I think 682 would just
think for damn's sake just leave me
alone given he's been through more
termination attempts than scp-5031 can
count on its fingers who could blame him
for getting a little frustrated Michael
Porter said I think that 682 and 096
would take each other to court for
aggravated assault against the other
either one of them will get sentenced to
death and will unsurprisingly not die or
the two team up to kill the entire
courtroom and they walk out as a new
serial killing team the real question is
what kind of lores would represent a
pair of murderous anomalous monsters in
court Better Call Saul Ari Workman said
maybe if we try being nice to them for
once we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both as a therapist 682 will
talk all his hate away and then realize
his wrongdoing and become an activist
and 096 would become very confident
about his face and become a model there
problem solved hey when people strive
towards self-improvement were for all
winners but we don't know if we can say
the same for 682 and 096 even if this
rematch ever did happen perhaps it'd be
just another draw an Unstoppable Force
against an immovable object but other
match-ups may be more clear-cut what
kind of versus battles would you like to
see us cover in the future what scps
would you really love to see duke it out
let us know in the comments and keep an
eye out on the community posts in order
to throw in your anomalous two cents for
our next versus Battle the military
helicopters sailed through the skies at
a steady Pace its destination somewhere
in Southwest Asia along one of the many
points where the legendary Euphrates and
Tigris Rivers meet depending on the
outcome this mission may have changed
the course of the SCP Foundation and its
activities forever or it might do
nothing at all such was often the way
when it came to dealing with the
unpredictable and the anomalous inside
the helicopter Dr Anton
was practically rattling with nervous
excitement ever since he'd been assigned
to the 682 termination detail after
years of wasting away in an archival
desk job he'd seen the kind of anomalies
you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
8 11 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose caustic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zarkov was particularly
astonished by the aftermath of the epic
battle between 096 and 6ab2 which left
both of these indestructible monsters
horribly maimed but all of that it was
nothing compared to what they were going
to witness today Dr zarkov muttered a
prayer to himself in frightened
reference Dr clef who was sitting across
from him in the helicopter wasn't quite
as wound up like some action movie
cliche made manifest he sliced Chung
chunks from a plump red apple with a
Bowie knife and suck the pieces off the
blade clef found zarkov's nervousness
little more than amusing first time
inside zero rookie clef asked between
apple slices Dr zarkov nodded forcing a
Meek smile clef just chuckled
ah you're wasting your time you know
Clough said everyone takes a shot at the
reptile I face it down myself once mono
imano during that moment I realized
something as much as it pains me to ever
throw in the towel We're not gonna kill
this thing it's just a budget sink of
course these kinds of doubts had cross
doctors arkov's mind before he'd watch
countless termination attempts organized
by far more senior researchers than
himself fail and fail embarrassingly
something about signing your name up for
682 termination was like tying on a
blindfold grabbing a bat and stepping up
to a pinata except in this case the
pinata isn't wearing a blindfold and
somehow it can hit you back it is a
one-way ticket to professional
humiliation and if you're unlucky enough
to get too close when things go south it
can be so much worse the Dr zarkov well
and truly believe that he would be the
exception to so much miserable failure
after all this was an idea nobody had
tried before an announcement over the
intercom signaled that they had now
entered site-0 airspace they'd be
landing shortly and just like that Dr
zarkov was all raised hairs and Goose
flesh once again it seemed like such a
hazy distant miracle that his project
proposal would even get majority
approval from the o5 council and now he
was about to touch down and actually see
it naturally Dr clef noticed Dr zarkov's
emotional cues and like so many
playground bullies decided to seize on
it don't buy into the hype Dr clef said
it's really not that special the
helicopter touched down Dr zarkov felt
defensive he was almost tempted to use
hard words but he realized from Dr
clef's mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention he
certainly had a reputation if one were
to put it in the most neutral terms
possible but this was your 001 proposal
Dr Cliff zarkov countered I would have
thought you'd be more invested in this
Dr klaff Rose to his feet and sheathed
his Bowie knife as the helicopter's side
door opened he gestured for Dr zarkov to
get up and follow him before saying
believe me even a giant flaming demigod
loses its luster when you need to write
enough of those stupid reports on it the
two researchers disembarked from the
helicopter and walked into the legendary
containment facility site zero one of
the most important and secretive
containment sites out there even by the
standards of the ever clandestine SCP
Foundation if ever containment
procedures failed here they'd be staring
down the barrel of an unprecedented
situation A Patmos XK us end of the
world scenario after all they were
dealing with one of the most serious and
Powerful anomalies they'd ever contained
here claf and zarkov entered the control
room filled with huge monitors
displaying every kind of recordable
metric but the largest screens were
dominated by long-range Drone footage of
the iconic anomaly they were all there
to see
scp-001 perhaps better known as Uriel
the gate Guardian while Dr clef remained
unfazed Dr zarkov felt a single tear
crawling down his cheek he had never
seen an entity so utterly awe-inspiring
an impossibly tall glowing humanoid
entity with eight great fiery wings and
a glowing blade made of pure Heavenly
Fire every bit as hot as the sun to
think that such an incredible creature
existed on the same Earth as him made
him feel so incredibly small the
theories as to the creature's true
nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundation's ranks even believe that
he is a direct servant of the abrahamic
god guarding the gate to Paradise the
Garden of Eden Heaven itself Dr klaff
just laughed everything you'd hope it'd
be zarkov he said Dr zarkov nodded and
more Dr Cliff and more even from such a
distance the raw power of the gate
Guardian is impossible to ignore it
radiates off of the being like an
invisible Aura Dr zarkov had read all
the files to get within a kilometer of
the mighty entity would be to court
death anyone who approached it would
taste the heat of its sword cleave them
apart at the atomic level and
effectively erasing them from existence
it's about as dead as anyone could
possibly be save for someone being
thrown into scp-3930 and literally
removed from the plane of existence
scp-3930 had failed to annihilate the
hard to destroy reptile but perhaps
where that whole lot of nothing had
failed the gate Guardian would succeed
to remain floating fixed on one place as
though waiting for something but what
perhaps a fateful confrontation with a
certain reptilian nightmare Dr zarkov
hoped like many he had heard the most
famous story involving scp-001 the gate
Guardian which took place before even
the days of the SCP Foundation after all
every Foundation needs a Founder doesn't
it and that's how it began the founder
was a mysterious figure no matter who
you ask some say it was 05-1 others say
it was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current o5 Council and administrator
a wise and learn figure going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual he
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
born witness to that's when the founder
felt a door open in the back of their
mind and something sneak in a single
word projecting somehow infinite
Authority
the very presence of the word made the
Founder's body rattle never had they
heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
could be anything else could it much
like Dr zarkov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare meant did it
mean to be ready for all the Terrible
Things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
Humanity didn't understand out there the
Founder's mind was flooded with so many
possibilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the Blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who would accept the knowledge of the
Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarkov had heard the story whispered
many times while conducting his research
into
scp-001 and now here he stood perhaps
where the founder hadn't been standing
all those years ago the SCP Foundation
had face down greater threats than
scp-682
the hanged King the sealed King The
Scarlet King hell if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the Burger King
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate Guardian
surely an ornery overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate Guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting Precious Cargo a chunk of
scp-682's Flesh cut from the Beast
itself currently it was attached to yet
another remote controlled drone set on a
collision course for the gate Guardian
Dr zarkov watched the video feeds with
sweaty Palms as he saw the Drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's View
getting closer to the gate Guardian by
the moment Closer Closer until the gate
Guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarkov found even
more exciting was the result in one
quick slash of its solar blade both the
Drone and the scp-682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash Dr zarkov's face split
into a mannequin if it could destroy the
tissue sample then surely it could
destroy the monster itself and what a
glorious day that would be meanwhile
back at the cross-testing chambers of
site 19
scp-682 was having another miserable day
it was dragged half melted out of its
acid tank at 3am in the morning and left
slowly regenerating on the floor a
typical SCP Foundation wake-up call it
thought to itself with the role of its
still regenerating eyes what form of
horrible torment would be in store for
it this time it began scrolling through
its mental Rolodex for the most recent
fail but painful termination attempts oh
yes of course they tried Suffocation via
vacuum that definitely made scp-682 feel
a little light-headed at least until of
course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing sadists a lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a
carapace made of solid helium to defend
it from the fire then shattering it to
shred a bunch of those buffoons in the
orange jumpsuits then they'd cut off a
sample of its flesh shoved it into some
absurd industrial blender before shoving
what's left into a centrifuge what a
Divine pleasure it had been for 682 to
hear the explosion down the hall when
the antimatter embedded in its genes
went off and put a number of those
idiotic Foundation drones in the
hospital for months serves them right to
continually meddling in the matters of
forces they couldn't even hope to
understand and today they were feeding
at the carcass of a dead cow
scp-682 side it felt sometimes that the
adults testing it had forgotten the note
reading highly intelligent on its file
being dragged into one of those ghastly
Chambers and given some form of Novel
stimulus could only mean one thing
something stupid and painful was going
to happen said stupid painful thing in
this case was that the cow was spiked
with an instance of
scp-3521 also known as the banana Pill
by dotto what followed was a remarkably
absurd instance even by scp-682
cross-test standards where a huge number
of bananas spontaneously burst out of
682's body being a big fan of bananas
apparently 682 was actually able to eat
and metabolize the bananas faster than
the anomalous banana Pill by dotto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individually slightly radioactive
682 was able to synthesize this
Collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great
deal of death and destruction as far as
Dr zarkov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
night to slay the Ultimate Dragon not
long after that
scp-682 was dosed up on enough sedatives
to give New York City a week-long nap
and carted over to site zero on a
heavily secured armored Convoy taking
scp-682 this far between containment
sites was considered a matter of grave
seriousness in other words the result of
this little experiment better have been
good to justify the insane security risk
it took to even get the damn lizard out
here Dr zarkov and Dr clef decided to
co-supervise the cross-test from the
safety of these site-0 observation deck
either would have been foolish to want
to get any closer even Dr klev while
undeniably a loose cannon didn't have an
outright Death Wish unless us of course
wishing death on scp-682 would count
682's sedated body was strapped to a
large unmanned vehicle the kind they
might use for an exploratory mission on
another planet and sent in the direction
of the gate guardian's deadly proximal
Zone a secondary camera drone was also
sent in to lag behind correctly
predicting that when the gate Guardian
Struck scp-682 it would obliterate the
unmanned vehicle too and whatever
happened out there the foundation needed
it on camera Dr zarkov had sweaty palms
and gritted teeth seeing the culmination
of his professional career unfold in
front of him Dr clef was looking at a
meme on his phone as 682 got closer it
began hearing a booming voice in its
head just like the founder had so long
ago the voice simply said one word over
and over getting louder as the unmanned
vehicle brought the two Titans closer
and closer and closer
682 still feeling groggy thought oh if
it only were so simple and then it
happened
scp-682 entered the dreaded one
kilometer range the guardian slashed
down with its mighty sword creating a
brilliant flash of light in the
aftermath the unmanned vehicle was
obliterated and 682 was left heavily
injured on the ground still trying to
process what had just happened 682
looked up sobered by the pain and saw
the being that had dealt this blow 682
began to sneer is this meant to be the
garden it said before breaking into a
venomous laugh
this is not the garden the garden is far
west of here the gate Guardian struck
again with its flaming blade once again
projecting that single word
When the Smoke cleared 682 was even more
horrifically injured with only one limb
left but still Against All Odds alive it
used the one limb to drag itself towards
the gate Guardian fueled by pure rage
and spite die you command me to die but
what do we all like that but this is my
curse for suggesting the fruit the
reptile ground back at the base Dr
zarkov was mortified how could it
possibly be surviving all this the sword
was meant to cleave apart its victims on
an atomic level Atomic is in freaking
atoms God damn it Dr zarkov was she had
a paper bag to breathe into Dr klaff
showing an uncharacteristic degree of
compassion padded zarkov on the back
saying it's okay buddy we all remember
our first time back at the center of the
action the gate Guardian blasted 682
with its solar blade again somehow
despite the terrifying Power Wheel did
by the guardian so 682 continued to live
it was alive barely but after three
strikes from The Sword to be alive with
whatever the evil version of a miracle
would be this is not the garden and you
are not Uriel 682 roared before spitting
at the gate Guardian Pretender one more
violent strike from the gate guardian
and 682 finally collapsed unconscious
from the extent of its pain and its
injuries but despite all of Dr zarkov's
hopes the gate Guardian did not strike a
killing blow on the unconscious Beast
instead it transmitted another word
another order impossible for any human
being to ignore
[Music]
as though in a trance the workers of
site zero including Dr zarkov and Dr
klaff entered the Forbidden one
kilometer exclusion Zone the gate
Guardian allowed them safe passage as
they used tools and vehicles to pick up
the heavily injured scp-682 and carted
away from the gate guardian's feet after
they all came back to their senses Dr
zarkov simply said what just happened Dr
clef just Shrugged I've learned to stop
questioning it greetings Brave
adventurers Seekers of knowledge
explorers of the great unknown no doubt
by now you've heard the stories of the
noble log Theodore Thomas Blackwood
gentlemen Explorer and naturalist also
known as
scp-1867 his exploits are known far and
wide though some question the validity
of his tales due to the simple fact that
he is a neon sea slug and not a human
man
these are of course fools we have even
covered Lord Blackwood before in a sea
snails fantasy scp-1867 Evan a gentleman
but never before have we taken a look at
such a daring account of his work today
we discuss a most curious Hunting
Expedition one that brought our Lord
Blackwood face to face with the great
Beast the hard to destroy reptile
scp-682 itself what will become of our
hero what sights will he see on his
journey let us find out
on May 14 1883 months after nearly
losing his life while climbing Mount
Everest Lord Blackwood received a letter
at his London home upon opening it he
saw that it was a formal invitation from
one Colonel Joseph default of the French
army it invited him to participate in a
hunt for a monster known as The Terrace
K that threatened the lives and security
of the French people anyone who was able
to slay the creature would receive a
handsome Award of five million pounds
for their trouble on able to resist a
challenge the chance to face off against
a creature he had never heard of before
or the Allure of such an impressive
prize Lord Blackwood sent off an
acceptance so what was the Terrace gay
Lord blackwood's research turned up a
fearsome description it was a massive
scaly creature with a high that seemed
impossible to pierce that breathed fire
and killed everything in its path
without batting an eye a worthy foe
indeed by the end of the day Lord
Blackwood had received an address where
he would attend a briefing before the
hunt would commence the meeting was held
in a private room in the city in an
exclusive Club there were three other
would-be Hunters there Mr Roosevelt from
America Mr dukov from Russia and Mr
Harris from England the colonel greeted
the man and told them what they were up
against a beast had laid waste to a
French Town ripping men women and
children to shreds and resisting every
blow dealt against it by the army so the
colonel vowed together expert scientists
and hunters for if they could not take
down the monster it was likely that no
one could on May the 20th the party
arrived in France to begin the Great
Adventure each man brought his own
armaments a combination of specialized
weapons and knowledge for the Tusk at
hand the following day the colonel
escorted the man to the quarantine Zone
where the beast's attack had led it Lord
Blackwood was troubled by the sights
there it was a city at War soldiers
patrolled the streets and barricades
were placed at the edge of town citizens
were being evacuated as soldiers aided
them and few had seen the Beast
themselves at least they had not been
unfortunate enough to see it up close
beyond the quarantine barrier it was
hell on Earth there were bodies laying
in the streets buildings burnt to the
ground castles and stone walls reduced
to piles of rubble there was not one
living thing in sight not a person a
farm animal or even so much as an insect
the men set up camp near the edge of
town and Mr Harris set about tracking
the Beast before too long he had found
it to the southwest and the next day
they would set off after it the next day
the party made its way Southwest to
Belleville following a trail of
Destruction there they found it having a
nap in the sun it was longer than a
whale taller than a giraffe and bigger
than both Lord Blackwood thought that if
it had any visible Wings he would
consider it a dragon they approached it
slowly careful not to wake the Terrace
Lord Blackwood crouched behind a fence
steadied his gun and fired right at its
head the shot hit and the top of the
Terrace case head came off with its
impact it seemed as if the Beast was
after so much Pomp and Circumstance dead
right there but sadly it was not it
sprang to life blood and brains dripping
from its open skull as it turned to the
men and roared then charged the men
scattered firing their guns as they ran
the monster gaining on them faster and
faster until Mr Tuka fired into its open
wound with an electric rifle it was
stunned long enough for the men to make
it onto their horses as they rode way
the monster continued to chase them new
skin and bone growing over what had once
been a hole in its skull Lord Blackwood
fired a particle destabilizer at its leg
tearing it off but as he watched in
horror the leg began to grow back The
Hunting Party managed to escape with
their lives though their confidence was
thoroughly shaken they rested that night
with the soldiers at the barricade they
attempted to attack the Terrace again
the following day but failed once more
the men realized that a simple gunshot
electrocution or fire would not be
enough to kill the monster it simply
healed too fast and its tolerance for
pain was too high in order to kill it
they realized they would have to render
it immobile and Destroy its body so
thoroughly that it would die before it
could rebuild itself and so they decided
to set a trap they dug a massive trench
wide in long enough for the monster and
deep enough that it would not be able to
climb out before they had killed it in
the bottom of the pit they had placed
hundreds of steel spikes the tips dipped
in poison they placed a bridge across it
strong enough for the men and horses but
weak enough to break under the Terrace
case weight and covered it all with
grass and leaves now they just had to
wait Mr Roosevelt acted as bait
approaching the monster on Horseback and
attacking it with a gunshot then running
and leading it back toward the Trap as
Roosevelt raced across the bridge the
creature pursued him and fell into the
pit where it was impaled on the spikes
then the man rained down Hell Fire they
shot it with bullets explosives jellied
kerosene Mr tukov I had a pitch blend
gun that upon firing released a blur of
smoke and fire once the fire had receded
all that remained was a skeleton the men
took the skull charred from the flames
and planned to take it back as a trophy
all was well also it seemed the men
returned to the town with a monster
skull and toe oh and the soldiers
cheered at the site they posed for
photographs and Mr dukov decided to pose
with his head between the jaws of the
Beast this was a grave mistake on his
part and the Jaws closed tight around
his neck his head falling to the ground
the skull acted on its own rolling and
biting all the while growing fresh skin
and scales it opened its gaping maw and
shouted
or for those of you that are not
familiar with the French language you
make me sick screams ran out behind Lord
Blackwood and he turned to see the rest
of the Terrace body a headless corpse
covered with stringy bits of muscle and
slowly growing brand new flesh it
stomped through the field crushing men
intense beneath its great feet on its
way to reclaim its head Mr Harris ran
for the bank vault to grab a weapon he
had only referred to previously as his
secret weapon Lord Blackwood chased
after him and found Harris pulling a
large crate which he opened with a sense
of desperation there inside was a
sarcophagus Bound in Chains and covered
in ancient runes Blackwood begged Harris
to leave the thing behind and run for
his life but he did not have a chance to
finish before Harris opened the lid and
an arm-wielding a sword emerged and
sliced his head from his body a man
emerged from the sarcophagus naked
wielding a sword covered in tattoos
Blackwood had no way of knowing this but
the man was none other than the deadly
Warrior
scp-076 or able the mysterious man
attacked Blackwood and Roosevelt and
though they tried to defend themselves
no weapon seemed to have an effect on
him he was preparing to deliver a final
blow to Blackwood and kill him once and
for all when the terrascape burst
through the wall of the building with a
mighty Bellow at the sight of the
enormous monster Abel turned his Focus
From the two men to the Beast and so the
two seemingly unkillable creatures
driven by bloodlust and inhuman strength
began to fight it took over an hour and
left destruction and death in its wake
Abel armed himself with explosives
mounting them to his chest along with
the pitch blend gun and ran towards the
Terrace knowing what would come next
Roosevelt and Blackwood locked
themselves in the bank vault and prayed
that someone would find them before they
starved to death after two days the men
were saved by a major of the army who
was leading a group of of soldiers in
search for any survivors they were taken
to a hospital and nursed back to health
by the staff there as well as a friend
of blackwood's named Henry the major who
rescued them told them that the colonel
was dead and so were ten thousand others
claimed by the massive explosion the
Terrace and Abel had both disappeared
and there was no indication of where
either of them had gone all that was
left was destruction and the memory that
a true monster had made itself known on
French soil no the only thing left to do
was recover as best as anyone could it
would certainly take a very long time
the Army was very suspicious of both
Roosevelt and Blackwood as the only
survivors of an explosion so large it
had been seen throughout France they
demanded to know how the two had
survived and what they had seen
throughout this process an Englishman
watched and took notes but did not speak
a word Roosevelt and Blackwood were
eventually released but they did not
receive a penny of their promised reward
and we're told they could not return to
France again for the rest of their lives
they were not to speak a word of what
they had seen to anyone or there would
be dire consequences in Calavera two
survivors said goodbye and Roosevelt
announced he would return to America to
pursue a career in politics who can say
what happened to him after that Upon
returning to his home in London Lord
Blackwood found that he had received a
postcard it read the Royal foundation
for the security containment and
protection of anomalous objects in
phantasmaguria requests a meeting for
the purpose of negotiating an alliance
favorable to both our parties please
call anytime except Sundays at number 19
Melbourne Road Westminster and asked to
speak to Dr Thursday your discretion is
requested in this matter he was puzzled
by this note unsure of what to make of
it perhaps he thought he could see what
they had to say after all he was always
curious and ready to explore new
territory once he had recovered
efficiently he would reach out to this
strange group and see what they might
have to offer him and so began a new
chapter of Lord blackwood's Story one
that included a mysterious organization
called the SCP Foundation now go check
out a sea snails fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman an scp-682 weighs
the SCP Foundation tried to kill the
hard to destroy reptile for more about
the two anomalies featured in today's
thrilling Tale